Das war's für heute.
So Leute, kurzer Streams.
Ich hab ja eigentlich gedacht, dass diese ganze Black Friday Geschichte jetzt rum ist, aber damit hab ich die Rechnung ohne Amazon gemacht.
Ich hab ja gar nicht dran gedacht, dass auf dem Black Friday im Monat gefühlt der Cyber Monday noch folgt.
Nicht, dass es da heute was Gescheites gibt, aber wir gucken mal kurz.
Ich hab jetzt eh nichts zu tun, ich war zwei Stunden wandern, ich hab gefuttert und eigentlich hab ich überlegt, hey, legst du dich mal kurz hin oder sowas, keine Ahnung.
Was weiß ich, ich mach einfach mal Stream an.
In der Natur tatsächlich.
Oh, morgen krieg ich was von Hermes, MonkaS. Hermes ist immer, ja, Hermes halt, ne, null.
Hermes, naja, gut.
Ah, Hermes halt.
Boombadingsbumsbadum, sechs Monate Dankeschön für den Sub.
Exzellent.
Oh ne, noch kein Hyper Subscriber, noch, noch, noch normaler.
Also guck mal, was es gibt, ich hab festgestellt, dass natürlich auch die ganzen China Shops das mitmachen, ne.
Also, die haben alle Banggood, wie gesagt, der Shop Name ist immer noch der allerbeste Online Shop Name aller Zeiten.
Die sind natürlich auch am Start hier, alles Cyber Monday, Cyber Monday, Cyber Monday, was ist mit DHgate?
Haben die auch Cyber Monday, wahrscheinlich haben die das selber.
Cyber Monday, was, diese ganzen China Shops, ne, diese ganzen China Shops, die sind alle von dem offiziellen China Web Design Ministerium gemacht worden.
Die sehen sich von der Aufmachung her, die sehen sich alles so ähnlich.
Auch hier guckt euch dieses Login Zeug an, das ist alles das Gleiche.
So muss das sein, Nico.
Ja, und alle sind dabei, bei allen gibt es quasi mehr oder weniger was umsonst.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass man hier Dinosaurier kaufen kann.
Was auch immer.
Oh, ach ne, ich hab mich verguckt, ich dachte, das wäre wirklich mal was Gutes, aber ist es nicht.
Ist es nicht.
Also wir gucken uns jetzt mal die üblichen Sachen an.
Also wir gucken uns mal an, was es in Computer gibt, gucken uns mal an, was es in Smart Home und in Werkzeuge gibt.
Das ist so eigentlich die Kategorien, die mich hauptsächlich interessieren.
Gutscheine ist jeder der sinnloseste Grab aller Zeiten.
Also Gutscheine kaufen ist ja nur wirklich Geld rausgeschmissen.
Das ist so ein exzellent Song, ja.
Cat Jam, wir haben doch jetzt alle Emotes am Start, Alter.
So, save on Happy Poo.
Was ist Happy Poo?
Peepo Poo?
Ist das nicht Arsch?
Dusche?
Ach guck mal da, als Wasserflasche.
Das ist quasi wie mein Klo nur to go.
Oh, mit Bürst und allem her.
Ich glaub nicht, dass das so toll ist.
Das ist wie mein Klo.
Warum ist da so ein Raspel?
Ah, okay, normales Klo Papier raspelt.
Ah, jetzt hab ich's verstanden.
Jetzt hab ich's kapiert.
Hat ein bisschen gedauert.
Low Brain, Alter.
Na ja, alles braucht keiner.
Mein Klo ist ja auch nur gut in Kombination.
Ganz ohne Klo Papier geht's trotzdem nicht, zumindest bei mir nicht.
Da kommt ja noch der Föhn dabei.
Und dass man auch variabel Wasser verstellen kann und es warm machen kann.
Ich glaube, das hier ist tatsächlich nicht so gut.
Wenn man unterwegs ist, meinetwegen mit der Feuchttüche oder so, wenn's sein muss.
Aber seitdem ich mein High-End Luxus Klo habe, gehe ich gar nicht mehr aufs Klo unterwegs.
Ich halt das immer ein, bis ich daheim bin.
Und dann daheim auf Super Klo.
Wir fangen mal hier.
Was haben wir hier?
Lightning Deals?
Ich wollte nicht Lightning Deals.
Ich wollte Tools.
Ich wollte Smart Home.
Ich wollte Computer.
Okay, Lightning.
Nein, wir sollen Lightning Deals angucken.
Heimscheißer.
Genau.
Beste.
Der eigene Klo ist eh der beste.
Sieht wahrscheinlich eh fast jeder so.
Gab es schon irgendwelche Highlights.
Ich habe vor zwei Minuten angemacht.
Aber so wie ich das aus anderen Sales bei Amazon kenne, gibt es wahrscheinlich wenig
Highlights.
Also was?
Blitzangebote.
Ah ja, ich brauche tatsächlich was.
Ich brauche ein paar IP68 oder was in der Richtung Boxen.
Aber sowas wird es da wahrscheinlich heute nicht im Angebot geben.
Äh ja, guck mal mal.
Also was haben wir denn hier schönes?
Handtücher.
Braucht keiner.
Er braucht schon Handtücher.
Das wird ja bedeutend.
Er wäscht sich auch.
Das ist ja nun mal wirklich, also abwegig.
So.
Powerbanks, diese Preise sind immer so heftiger.
G-Bate.
Übrigens wisst ihr was auch G-Bate ist?
Vodafone ist richtiger G-Bate.
Ich habe gestern Abend geschrieben auf Twitter.
Aber gestern Abend, ich wollte ins Bett und wollte noch einen Stream gucken.
Ging nicht, weil Vodafone im Arsch ist.
So, da habe ich mir gedacht, weißt du was?
Du machst einfach, also du machst einfach 3G und gehst pennen und dann wird es schon
wieder gehen.
Da bin ich heute Morgen aufgemacht, sieben Stunden später.
Und habe festgestellt, es geht immer noch nicht.
Und dann noch mal drei Stunden später ging es immer noch nicht.
So, und dann habe ich denen geschrieben, also das ist jetzt quasi das dritte Mal, also
das zweite Mal hier, wo ich dann an Vodafone direkt geschrieben habe.
Normalerweise kriegen die sowas hier schon immer mit.
Hat immer noch keiner darauf reagiert gehabt.
Aber ohne Scheiß, eine Viertelstunde später ging es wieder.
Die, ich vermute, die haben noch was gemacht.
Oh, beste.
Exzellent Musik.
Ketchem.
Na ja, zumindest eine Viertelstunde später ging es wieder.
Und im Nachhinein betrachtet, glaube ich, das war irgendeine Wartungsarbeit von Vodafone,
die sie nicht eingekündigt haben.
Weil, das ging fort.
Guckt euch mal die Zeiten an.
Ich habe das hier gepostet um, das sind elf, zwei, ne, drei, hä?
Stimmt, ich habe das um 22 Uhr, 23 Uhr?
23 Uhr habe ich das gepostet.
Okay.
Und das habe ich gepostet um neun.
Ey Leute, 23 Uhr bis neun.
So glatt ist normalerweise kein Ausfall.
Ich sehe hier Illuminati.
Und kurz nach neun ging es wieder.
Das stimmt doch, war es nicht.
Hallo, was ist mit der Musik los?
Ah, das ist Pokémon, muss ich aber trotzdem nicht übertreiben, please.
Ähm, das kann doch kein Zufall sein.
23 oder 22 Uhr, das ging ja vorher schon nicht.
22 Uhr bis neun Uhr.
Das ist so glatt.
Die kommen ja auf die Ideen der Primetime.
Ich weiß bei Vodafone eh nicht auf was für Ideen die sonst noch so kommen.
Bei Vodafone ist das eh alles, denen ist das eh alles egal mittlerweile.
Ganz schön langes Warnungsfenster, ja.
Das ist verdammt langes Warnungsfenster.
Ein halber Tag Warnungsfenster.
Aber wundert es dich?
Oder wird es dich wundern?
Also mich würde Vodafone nicht mehr wundern.
So, also exzellent, zeige ich mal her.
Was haben die hier so?
Komische Hütchen, brauchen wir alles nicht.
HDMI-Kabel, Ivanky.
Was ist das denn?
Ist das nicht die Frau von Trump?
Oder ist es Ivanky?
Beides nicht so toll vom Namen her.
So.
Das sind HDMI-Kabel, die keiner braucht.
Also wenn ich eins mittlerweile genug habe, sind es HDMI-Kabel.
Zwar keine super High-End China 4K-HDMI-Kabel.
Aber HDMI-Kabel habe ich genug.
Ich habe auch kein Gerät, 4K.
Warte mal, mein Fernseh.
Doch, doch, doch.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Mein Fernseh ist der mit, der muss mit HDMI angeschlossen sein, oder?
Fernsehe haben keinen Display-Port, oder?
Und das Shield-TV hat auch keinen Display-Port-Ausgang.
Der Fernseh muss per HDMI angeschlossen sein und mit dem Kabel ging es.
Und das war kein super krasses 4K-HDMI-Kabel.
Das ging einfach mit 4K.
Der Friseur hat wieder ein Video gemacht.
Ja, ich weiß.
Stellt euch mal vor, ich habe den Friseur auch noch abonniert.
Oder hat tatsächlich noch ein Video gemacht, ja.
Wieso eigentlich TV mit HDMI?
Na ja, weil im TV-Umfeld halt HDMI so das Ding ist.
Da kannst du dich ja nicht aussuchen.
Etwas off-topic, aber hast du schon mitbekommen, wie Corona finanziert werden soll?
Unsere Finanzminister fordern wohl schon Erhöhung des Spitzensteuersatzes.
Die haben alle den Arsch offen.
Gut, unser Finanzminister ist ja auch der, der Kanzlerkandidat bei der SPD werden will.
Also, jetzt mal.
Ganz kurz meine Zwei sind zu dieser Geschichte.
Wir machen gleich weiter.
Spitzensteuersatz schön und gut.
Ob man den Spitzensteuersatz vielleicht ein bisschen erhöhen sollte, kann man darüber diskutieren.
Aber was ich komplett affisch finde in Deutschland ist, ab wann du den Spitzensteuersatz bezahlen musst.
Ich muss Spitzensteuersatz bezahlen.
Ich bin nicht reich oder so.
Du musst in Deutschland ja schon, wenn du halbwegs ordentlich verdienst, musst du Spitzensteuersatz bezahlen.
Spitzensteuersatz sollte meiner Meinung nach was sein, was halt wirklich reiche Leute bezahlen müssen.
Nicht der 0815 Streaming, YouTube, Teilzeitarbeitsspaß, der hier vorm Rechner sitzt.
Kann doch nicht sein.
Es ist aktuell so, dass quasi das, was man mittelschicht genannt hat, komplett am aussterben ist.
Du hast Leute, die rutschen total ab und können keinerlei Kapitalvermögen, was auch immer aufbauen.
Du hast welche, ein paar, die rutschen nach oben, die kriegen ultra viel Kohle.
Und das, was mal so in der Mitte war, also da wo ich jetzt gerade bin,
die gehören quasi fast schon zu den Reihen vom Verhältnis her, was die Leute haben.
Zu den Reichen.
Ich bin doch nicht reich.
Ich hab keinen goldenen BMW oder irgendwie so ein Scheiß hier stehen.
Ich komm ganz gut über die Runden.
Ich hab auch, ich hab ein Haus.
Ich verdien ganz gut, aber es ist nicht so, dass ich reich wäre in irgendeiner Art und Weise.
Was ist das für ein Schwachsinn?
Und gerade die Leute, die müssen das bezahlen.
Und gerade die Leute müssen das bezahlen.
Natürlich fuck mich das besonders ab, weil ich davon betroffen bin.
Ja, also.
So, das reicht jetzt auch.
Aber das finde ich total hängen geblieben.
Die können meinetwegen sogar den Spitzensteuersatz eventuell ein bisschen höher machen,
aber meiner Meinung nach wäre es viel, viel sinnvoller.
Man würde gucken, dass man den Spitzensteuersatz eben so macht,
dass du Spitze bezahlst, wenn du halt auch Spitze hast.
Und nicht so einen anderen Kack, wie es jetzt ist.
Ich mein, was sollen denn noch, was sollen die Leute dann noch alles mit bezahlen?
Die Musik ist seltsam, das ist hier Top 100 Nintendo Songs.
Ich finde die Musik äußerst Pepe Jam.
Ja, das, was Tribolon sagt, ist vollkommen richtig.
Ich habe letztens ein Video darüber geguckt, dass du früher umgerechnet,
also wenn man ein bisschen zurückgeht, was weiß ich, 1984 oder so,
wenn du da geguckt, wenn du da das hochrechnest, was da der Spitzensteuersatz war,
da musstest du ultra viel verdienen.
Ich sage jetzt einfach mal 250.000 Euro oder sowas im Jahr mindestens.
Ich weiß die Zahlen nicht mehr.
Ultra viel im Vergleich zu jetzt.
Also nicht für damals, wenn du es hochrechnest, auf jetzt.
Das wäre dann auch okay gewesen.
Aber es kann doch nicht sein, dass jeder Typ, der ordentlich verdient,
die Chance hat, so ein bisschen Geld aufzubauen, ein bisschen Vermögen aufzubauen,
dass der gnadenlos voll besteuert wird.
Genau, damals war es das 15-Fahrer, richtig.
Ganz ehrlich, ich weiß nicht, was bei uns los ist.
Was ist denn mit der Musik? Die Musik ist zu laut gerade.
Exzellent.
Ja, ja, was auch immer.
Das ist übrigens meiner Meinung nach eigentlich somit das größte Problem,
das wir haben, dass der Unterschied zwischen Arm und Reich immer größer wird.
Und lustigerweise, die Leute mit allem anderen beschäftigt sind,
als sich mit dieser elementaren Frage mal auseinanderzusetzen.
Was ist eigentlich los?
Warum bleibt mir so wenig übrig von dem Geld, was ich eigentlich bekomme?
Warum ist davon eigentlich nichts mehr da?
Warum gibt es so viele Leute in Deutschland, die quasi von Monatsgehalt zu Monatsgehalt leben?
Für die ist das, also es ist für ganz viele Leute in Deutschland unvorstellbar,
dass die spontan einfach mal sich ein 2000 Euro Fernseh kaufen.
Obwohl die Vollzeit arbeiten gehen und quasi schaffen ohne Ende,
ist es bei denen nicht drin, dass sie mal sagen, okay, jetzt gönne ich mir mal irgendwas.
Die sind quasi am Ende des Monats schon im Minus
und schaffen es dann gerade mal über die Runden mit ihrem nächsten Gehalt.
Vielleicht können sie am Weihnachten, wenn sie mal doppelt was kriegen, ein bisschen was kaufen.
Das kann so nicht sein.
Du solltest nicht arbeiten, also dein Leben sollte nicht aus Arbeit bestehen.
Du solltest arbeiten gehen, dass du ein schönes Leben führen kannst.
Und wenn einer arbeiten geht, sollte er auch ein schönes Leben führen können.
Und nicht von Monatsgehalt zu Monatsgehalt.
Wenn du da drin stehst, du lebst ja nur noch, dass du arbeiten kannst von einem Monat zum anderen.
Das ist mega beschissen.
Warum ich doch auf OBS 24 bin? Weil ich noch nicht abgecrayt habe.
Ich weiß, da wäre jetzt nie drauf gekommen.
Hat keinen Sinn.
OBS 26 hat richtig nice Features.
Nämlich man kann jetzt die VOD Tracks für Twitch mit anderer Musik versorgen.
Also sprich, ich kann jetzt hier im Stream Metallica spielen.
Und im VOD wäre dann Free Chills der Playlist oder sowas.
Eigentlich ziemlich gut.
Ja, aber ich belasse es jetzt. Das ist meine Meinung dazu.
Ich finde das voll für einen Arsch.
Ich finde das richtig für einen Arsch.
Und auch was mir persönlich, das muss ich jetzt noch dazu sagen.
Wir beschäftigen uns ja mit allen möglichen.
Bloß nicht mit uns.
Die Leute kommen nicht auf die Idee, das mal zu hinterfragen.
Zu sagen, wie kann das eigentlich sein, dass ich, gehen wir jetzt mal von einem Austern ein bisschen weniger verdiene.
25, 30k im Jahr oder so.
Wie kann es denn sein, dass ich von meinen 30k gerade so viel habe, dass ich über die Runden komme.
Obwohl ich 8 Stunden am Tag arbeiten gehe.
Die Frage stellen sich die Leute nicht.
Und ich finde das ist eigentlich die wichtigste Frage, die es mal mehr Leute stellen sollten.
Nicht, was weiß ich, wie können wir die ganze Welt retten.
Wie können wir hier machen, wie können wir sonst was machen.
Die Leute sollen sich mal ein bisschen auf sich selbst, sie sollen sich mal ein bisschen Gedanken darüber machen, was das eigentlich soll.
Du bist 8 Stunden am schaffen und hast von deiner Kohle nichts.
Und dann kommt da noch dazu, das was mir auf den Sack geht.
Das wenn du siehst, wo dein Geld hinläuft.
Oder besser gesagt, wo du siehst, wo die Steuern, die du bezahlen, wo die nicht hinlaufen.
Nämlich halt in die Sachen, die mir persönlich wichtig sind, läuft es nicht hin.
Guckt euch mal in den Internetausbau, in den Infrastrukturausbau generell.
Guckt euch mal an, was für einen Zustand bei uns Krankheitssystemen, Kindergärten, Straßen, Tierheimen, was auch immer haben.
Die Sachen, die mir wichtig sind, kommt die Kohle irgendwie nicht an.
Und da muss man sich ja fragen, ok, ich muss irgendwie, ich krieg noch einen Bruchteil von der Kohle, die ich quasi erarbeite.
Krieg ich raus und mit dem Geld, was mir abgezogen wird, wird noch nicht mehr das gemacht, was ich gerne hätte.
Das ist doch mega, mega, ganz in meinem Ernst.
Das ist eigentlich das, was ich mal wirklich meiner Meinung nach mehr Leute fragen müssen.
Was da eigentlich abgeht überhaupt, was das eigentlich soll.
Und deswegen, ich, ihr wisst ja, dass ich jahrelang mich nicht entscheiden konnte, was ich wählen soll.
Terox, 12 Monate, Dankeschön.
Und ich kann mich immer noch nicht wirklich, 12 Monate ist schon richtig krasse Hyper-Hyper-Subscription.
Ähm, ähm, was soll ich jetzt sagen?
Äh, richtig, das, Jupp, sehe ich ganz genau so, sehe ich ganz genau so.
Ähm, die, man kann sich da um die Details, man kann sich da um die Details streiten,
aber mehr übertriebene Regulierung und mehr aufgeplädtes Zeug macht die Sache garantiert nicht besser.
Sehe ich, sehe ich auch so.
Ja, und ich, wie gesagt, ich wusste jahrelang nicht, was ich wählen sollte.
Ich hab auch, ich war immer wählen, ich hab aber meistens ungültig gewählt.
Ähm, ich hab mich bei der letzten Europawahl dazu hinreißen lassen, die Grünen zu wählen,
die ich im Nachhinein für total bescheuert halte.
Ja, ähm, aber jetzt, ich tendiere, so doof es klingt, ja, ich hab mir, ich lese mir die Programme manchmal ein bisschen durch
und von allendem, leider haben die keine Chance, von allendem muss ich ehrlich sagen,
wo ich mich noch am ehesten wiederfinde, ist tatsächlich die FDP.
Hätte ich nie gedacht, dass ich mal irgendwann in Erwägung ziehe, die FDP zu wählen.
Tribulon, exakt, so geht es mir auch.
Ich meine, die werden nichts reißen, die werden auch nichts machen können am Ende.
Aber, und was die sagen und zwischen dem, was sie am Ende machen, sind ja immer zur komplett weilenweiten Unterschiede.
Aber nur weil man mal rein von dem ausgeht, was da wirtschaftlich erzählt wird,
was da so generell so ein bisschen so, wie soll ich sagen, ein bisschen Weltanschauungsmittel erzählt wird,
sehe ich mich aktuell tatsächlich am ehesten bei der FDP.
Ja, naja gut, aber das kann sich ja noch ändern, 2021 ist es erst so,
wahrscheinlich werde ich wieder ungültig wählen, weil mir am Ende alle auf den Sack gehen.
Oder ich wähle die bibeltreuen Christen, genau, exzellent.
Ja, die, die brauchen wir unbedingt, die brauchen wir ja, die brauchen wir unbedingt, das stimmt.
Oder ich wähle, wenn ich ohne Scheiß, wisst ihr was ich mache,
wenn ich immer noch nicht weiß, wen ich wählen soll 2021,
dann wähle ich die Tierschutzpartei.
Bäm.
So, ich habe NPD, gibt es die NPD überhaupt noch?
Sind die nicht alle bei der AfD jetzt? Onstream war Lomard.
Jetzt machen wir, machen wir, ja.
Obwohl, ich glaube, die sind nicht mehr alle bei der AfD.
Das war denn nicht mehr radikal genug, da sind ja viele wieder weg
und viele haben dann auch alternative Sachen gegründet,
noch mal Alternative, zur Alternative und solche Dinger.
Da sind ja viele wieder weg, die hatten keinen Bock mehr da drauf
und gesagt haben, wie, das ist, das ist uns nicht radikal genug, das,
da haben wir keinen Bock mehr drauf, da muss, da muss, muss, muss mehr zur Sache gehen.
Was ist denn die Bierpartei, Alter?
Ich habe im letzten Walomard, wurde mir vorgeschlagen, ohne Scheiß,
wir haben es onstream gemacht, den Walomard, den hier,
aber D für die, ich glaube, für die Europawahl haben wir den.
Wir haben den Walomard gemacht und da ist rausgekommen,
ich soll entweder AfD oder die Partei wählen.
Excellent.
Ja, letztendlich wäre die Partei wahrscheinlich nicht schlecht gewesen.
Aber wir machen den Walomard wieder onstream, ja.
Ich weiß noch, ich weiß noch, so ein Ding, da gab es irgendeine Frage drin,
wollen sie oder sind sie dafür, dass quasi Leute, die hier,
ich weiß nicht mehr, wie es beschrieben wird, quasi Leute, die hier arbeiten gehen,
aber sagen wir aus Schweden, England, sonst wo irgendwoher kommen,
dass die lokal wählen dürfen.
So, und da habe ich gesagt, nö.
So, und das war halt, das war halt irgendwie die Position,
wo halt das nur irgendwie auch zur AfD und die Partei gepasst hat, keine Ahnung.
Die anderen haben alle gesagt, ja, und ich denke, das ist immer noch, warum?
Also ganz ehrlich, wenn ich irgendwo hingehe und da nicht Staatsbürger bin,
dann habe ich da auch gefälligst nicht zu wählen.
Also, weiß gar nicht, wie man auf die Idee kommt.
Das geht mich da überhaupt nichts an.
Ich meine, natürlich wäre es schön, wenn man irgendwie in einer gewissen Art
mitbestimmen könnte.
Aber ich meine, ich habe nun mal als Staatsbürger gewisse Privilegien,
die ich in anderen Ländern habe.
Deswegen, ich kann ja weiter in meinem Land wählen.
Ist doch okay, ja.
Ich habe beispielsweise einen Kumpel auf der Arbeit.
Kann ich so sagen, ist zwar ein Kollege, aber wir verstehen uns ziemlich gut.
Der kommt aus den USA.
Oder zumindest der Vater kommt aus den USA.
Also da kriegst du ja automatisch einen Pass.
Und der macht auch immer Briefwahl.
Der ist da nie, aber der wählt da auch mit.
Ist ja okay, der ist ja auch amerikanischer Staatsbürger.
Aber wenn ich jetzt Engländer bin oder Schwede bin oder so,
oder wenn ich in Schweden bin, dann mache ich mir doch gar keine Gedanken.
Dann komme ich nicht mal auf die Idee, dass ich in Schweden mitwählen will.
Vielleicht was wirklich Lokales, aber das hat am Endeffekt eh kaum Auswirkungen.
Naja, also...
Ja, Martin, das denke ich auch.
Die waren wahrscheinlich im Prinzip dagegen und die Partei hat getrollt.
Das kann schon sein, ja.
Naja, so, wir gucken uns jetzt aber Amazon an.
Exzellente.
Iiih, was ist das denn?
Jetzt sehe ich das Richtige, das ist ein VGA auf HDMI.
Was zum...
Warum sollte ich denn so was machen?
Für Beamer vielleicht, für Boomer-Beamer.
Für Schulequipment.
In der Schule haben die bestimmt noch VGA-Beamer.
Leute, als ich in die Schule gegangen bin,
da war ein Overhead-Projektor noch voll angesagt.
Da haben die Lehrer immer auf einem Overhead-Projektor rumgekritzelt.
Und zu der Zeit gab es dann auch später noch VGA-Beamer.
Und die VGA-Beamer haben die heute noch.
Und wenn die ihre VGA-Beamer an irgendwas Modernes anschließen wollen,
brauchen sie so einen Kack-Adapter.
Die gibt es immer noch, ja.
Kennt ihr euch...
Ich weiß nicht, wie das bei euch in der Schule war,
aber bei uns war es damals so der neueste Shit,
oder eigentlich war es nicht der neueste Shit,
es war auch schon damals alt,
dass es so Wagen gab mit einem Fernseh drin und einem Videorekorder.
Und da haben die Lehrer dann ab und zu mal irgendwelche Physik-Sendungen
und sowas abgespielt auf dem Fernsehen,
wenn die keinen Bock haben, Unterricht zu machen.
Dann hat man sich dann irgendwie so eine Sendung angeguckt.
Moment, mal gucken, ob es sowas in der Richtung gibt.
Was weiß ich.
Das Atom.
Alt.
Alter Film.
Das wird ja gar nicht wangreich.
So Dinge hat man sich da angeguckt in Physik.
Viel zu neu alles, viel zu neu.
Ja, so Dinge hat man sich da in der Schule anguckt.
Und dann war es so,
dass unglaublich viele Lehrer,
frage ich mich bis heute, wie das geht,
nicht in der Lage waren, diesen Videorekorderwagen zu bedienen.
Die haben dann immer diesen Videowagen geholt
und wussten nicht, wie der Scheiß angeht,
wo ich mir denke, das sind doch nur zwei Knöp.
Wie kann man das nicht schaffen?
Da muss dann immer der Streber vom Dienst vorkommen
und dem Lehrer den Videorekorder und Fernseher einschalten,
weil der Lehrer zu doof war.
Weiß nicht, ob das bei euch vielleicht auch so gewesen ist, aber...
Vorspulen.
Ja, was ja erschreckend ist, was ja erschreckend ist,
dass das bei vielen heute noch so ist.
Aber ernsthaft, Videowagen?
Da wundert mich ja nichts mehr.
So was haben wir nicht geguckt.
Wir haben so Physik-Sendungen geguckt.
Die Musik willst du aber echt wissen.
Wir haben so Physik-Sendungen geguckt von so einem Typ.
Da kann ich mich heute noch dran erinnern.
Der hat alles so besonders betont ausgesprochen.
Der hat nicht gesagt, das ist ein Elektron oder so.
Der hat gesagt, es ist ein Elektron, ein Elektron.
Vielleicht kennt das hier was.
Das Elektron.
An den Kack kann ich mich heute noch erinnern.
Ja, schon geil, dass das immer noch so ist, oder?
2015-Abi-Overhead-Projektor.
Ach du Scheiße.
Das ist auch nicht schlecht.
Einmal muss ich mal überlegen.
Ja, so was.
So was haben wir geguckt, genau.
Ja, so eine Kacke haben wir damals geguckt.
So was haben wir damals geguckt, genau.
Exzellent Quali.
So Krempel haben wir damals geguckt.
So in der Machart.
Aber nicht von diesem Typ.
Ich mein, man muss sich doch nicht wundern.
Guck mal, wenn wir hier Leute haben, die 2019, 2015,
oder sogar noch 2010 so was in der Schule sich geben mussten.
Da muss man sich doch nicht wundern,
dass das mit Digitalisierung
und ein bisschen fortschrittlich im Kopf sein und so.
Dass das nicht funktioniert, oder?
Wo soll denn das herkommen?
Ich mein, vom Baum fällt das nicht.
Genau, da hat man richtig Bock, Physik zu studieren,
wenn man sowas geguckt hat, ja.
Nee, nee, also das...
Ja, und dann wundert man sich,
jetzt wo Corona am Start ist,
ob das mit Remote-Unterricht nicht.
Ja klar, weil 90% der Lehrer nie gelernt haben,
mit Technik irgendwie umzugehen.
Mittlerweile ist es wahrscheinlich ein bisschen besser,
weil auch viele jüngere Lehrer am Start sind.
Der Lehrer bei mir in der Berufsschule,
der hat immer World of Warcraft Forum gelesen,
nebenbei, der war ja auch ein bisschen jünger,
der war so alt, wie ich jetzt bin, ungefähr.
Ähm, und ansonsten kann es auch komplett,
kann es komplett knicken.
Die schaffen es nicht.
Es gibt zu wenig Lehrer, die das überhaupt können.
Die meisten sind dazu gar nicht in der Lage.
Und ich erzähl's dir immer gerne.
Einen, wo ich gerade erzählt habe,
der amerikanische Staatsbürger ist da von mir auf der Arbeit,
der hat eine Tochter in Kolumbien, glaube ich,
und der hat mir erzählt, in Kolumbien,
die machen seit einem halben Jahr nur Remote-Unterricht.
Oh, das klappt.
Ich meine, Kolumbien!
Nichts gegen Kolumbien!
Aber wenn man so mal auf ein Papier guckt,
wer könnte es besser technisch, organisatorisch
und infrastrukturell hinbekommen mit Remote-Unterricht?
Deutschland oder Kolumbien?
Wenn man da mal international so eine Umfrage machen würde,
würden natürlich alle sagen, ja klar Deutschland,
Deutschland ist ja recht fortschrittlich.
Aber, wenn man ehrlich ist, nein, es ist Kolumbien.
Kolumbien kriegt es hin.
Wir kriegen es jetzt so ansatzweise hin.
Also auch einer ist Lehrer,
und der hat jetzt auch manchmal Remote-Unterricht und so.
Aber ja, nicht so wirklich gut, ja.
Kind geht dort auf eine Privatschule.
Keine Ahnung, ehrlich gesagt.
Also so viel Geld,
dass die sich da irgendeine Privatschule leisten können,
hat der, glaube ich, nicht.
Ja, gut.
Da hast du recht.
Guck dir die Ottos an, für die Digitalisierung zustellen.
Das ist richtig.
Ja, da hast du recht.
Guck dir die Ottos.
Die Dingsartikel.
Was Artikel?
13, Artikel 15, 17.
Ich habe es schon wieder vergessen.
Oder jetzt, guck dir die Ottos an.
Die diese Verschlüsselungsgeschichte gerade durchgewunken haben.
Habt ihr das mitbekommen?
Ja, genau.
Hier.
Habt ihr den gerade mitbekommen?
Das ist so realitätsfern, was da beschlossen wurde.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Du kannst nicht sagen, es ist nur teilweise verschlüsselt.
So nach dem Motto, du darfst es verschlüsseln,
aber es muss für uns entschlüsselbar bleiben.
Ja, das ist im Prinzip TLDR.
Die sagen, ja, ist okay, verschlüsselt,
aber sorgt dafür, dass ihr es für uns entschlüsseln könnt.
Aber der Witz ist ja, das funktioniert ja nicht.
Das ist ja nicht die Art und Weise, wie Verschlüsselung funktioniert.
Deswegen sage ich ja auch immer, wenn es irgendeinen Anbieter gibt,
wo ihr Daten hochladen, also der sagt, sie verschlüsseln eure Daten,
und ihr habt euer Passwort vergessen,
und der Anbieter kann das euch wieder herstellen,
in irgendeiner Art und Weise, wenn ihr sowas vergessen habt,
dann ist es nicht richtig verschlüsselt.
Also eines der elementarsten Sachen, wenn es um Verschlüsselung geht, ist,
Passwort weg, Daten weg.
Das ist ganz einfach.
Und was man bei, verwendet einer von euch vielleicht Truecrypt
oder Veracrypt, um seine Festplatte zu verschlüsseln.
Die sagen am Anfang, man soll eine Backup-CD anlegen,
oder Backup-USB-Stick oder sowas,
aber das ist glaube ich das, was auch viele falsch verstehen.
Das ist kein Backup, wenn du dein Passwort vergessen hast.
Das Backup von Veracrypt ist nicht dafür da,
wenn du dein Passwort vergessen hast.
Das Backup von Veracrypt ist dafür da,
wenn deine Festplatte auf den Veracrypt-Sektoren beschädigt ist,
sodass Veracrypt die eigentlichen Keys
nicht mehr mit deinem Passwort entschlüsseln kann,
weil die Keys kaputt sind.
Also Veracrypt macht es ja so, du hast auf der Festplatte,
vorne auf der Festplatte, also das hier,
du hast vorne auf der Festplatte,
ihr seht auch, ich habe mein System komplett verschlüsselt,
allein schon aus dem Grund,
weil ich die Festplatte einfach in den Müll schmeißen kann dann.
Veracrypt macht das so,
die schreiben vorne auf die Festplatte,
Keys und die schreiben die gleichen Keys
nochmal hinten auf die Festplatte.
Warum?
Falls die Festplatte kaputt geht.
Eventuell ist vorne nicht mehr lesbar, hinten aber noch.
Vorne wird auch mal ganz gern überschrieben,
falls Windows Scheiße baut oder wie auch immer.
Aber diese Keys, die sind wiederum mit eurem Passwort verschlüsselt,
was ihr eingeben müsst beim Starten.
Bei Lux ist es genauso, bei Lux ist es ganz genauso.
Das Passwort, was ihr eingebt, ist nicht wirklich das Passwort,
was verwendet wird, um hier Verschlüsselung zu machen.
Das funktioniert unter der Haube nicht richtig,
weil die Keys müssen eine gewisse Länge haben,
das ist ein bisschen komplizierter.
Aber die Keys, die Veracrypt auf der Platte speichert,
einmal vorne, einmal hinten,
die sind mit eurem Passwort verschlüsselt.
Das heißt, wenn ihr das Passwort vergessen habt,
dann bringt euch auch die Recovery-CD nichts.
Die Recovery-CD oder die Recovery-USB-Stick
ist nur dafür da, wenn die Festplatte beschädigt ist.
Wie verhält sich das mit einem Zwei-Platt?
Ist der Anfang und Ende physisch?
Nein, logisch.
Also so, wie es der Controller ausgibt.
Quasi erster Sektor, letzter Sektor.
Wie das unter der Haube der SSD-Controller handelt,
hat das keine Ahnung von.
Ne, ne, also mit hinten und vorne ist das gemeint,
was der Controller meldet.
Da gibt es ja logischerweise immer einen hinten und vorne.
Ob das jetzt wirklich auf dem, wenn du die SSD aufschraubst,
ob das der erste Chip ist in der linken unteren Ecke
und dann der letzte Sektor im rechten oberen Eck ist,
das ist natürlich sehr unwahrscheinlich.
Aber wenn du dir die Sachen anguckst auf Betriebssystem-Ebene,
dann hast du schon irgendwo was, wo das Medium anfängt,
wo das Medium aufhört, also sprich, was dir der Controller meldet.
Exzellent, eigentlich wollten wir Amazon gucken.
Kann man eigentlich auch DVDs oder Blu-rays verschlüsseln?
Klar.
Du kannst alles verschlüsseln.
Du kannst prinzipiell alles verschlüsseln.
Wo davon wieder am Start?
Ja, zum Glück.
Passportmanager ist schon mal ein guter Anfang.
Da bist du besser als 99% der Leute auf der Welt,
wenn du einen ordentlichen Passportmanager verwendest.
Es ist auch erst mal nicht so wichtig, welcher.
Ich persönlich schwöre jetzt seit Jahren auf Key Pass,
aber es hängt ein bisschen von ab, was man machen will.
Bitworn ist ganz gut, wenn man unterwegs drauf zugreifen will
oder sich aufs Handy sinken will oder irgendwelche Geschichten.
Ich benutze halt, One Passport kann ich noch nicht verwenden,
kann nichts zu sagen.
Aber generell Sachen, wo alles in der Cloud gespeichert wird,
bin ich jetzt kein Freund von.
Wenn es um Google Passportmanager oder sonst was geht...
Also, wenn in die Cloud dann nur, wenn ich sichergestellt habe,
dass es vom Upload verschlüsselt ist, was man schlecht kann,
weil kaum einer die Software verifiziert, die da verwendet wird.
Leute, die big brain sind und sich alles merken können,
können es natürlich auch im Kopf machen.
Aber ich habe mittlerweile 130 oder so was um den Dreh
Accounts da drin in meinem Passportmanager.
Also, viel Spaß, das im Kopf zu merken.
Ja, Bitworn ist okay.
Äh, übrigens, das hier, ne?
Passportmanager für Boomer, Notizzettel in Schreibtischschublade.
Das ist gar nicht übel.
Passwörter auf einem Zettel.
Wisst ihr, was nämlich der riesen Vorteil ist
auch gegenüber einem Passwortsafe?
Also, wenn mich einer fragt, Max, was ist sicherer?
Einen verschlüsselten Passwortsafe wie KeyPass oder einen Zettel?
Dann muss ich eben ganz ehrlich antworten, der Zettel ist sicherer.
Also, wenn es rein darum geht, wie sicher das ist,
dass es jemanden mitschneidet, der Zettel ist sicherer.
Weil der Zettel hat einen unglaublichen Vorteil
gegenüber so einem Passportmanager.
Da ist so eine Mediengrenze dazwischen.
Sprich, das eine ist halt auf dem Computer gespeichert.
Sprich, wenn jemand bei euch einen Backdoor-Keylogger
oder was auch immer installiert hat,
dann kann man relativ easy so einen KeyPass abgreifen.
Wir hatten zum Beispiel mal auf der Arbeit,
hatten wir mal ein Virus oder was auch immer es war.
Aber haben die Leute wieder auf E-Mail-Anhänge geklickt.
Glücklicherweise bin ich dafür in der Zustände,
ich hab das nur mitgekriegt.
Und die haben sich ein Virus eingefangen,
der KeyPass-Dateien dumpt.
Also sprich, das Ding hat drauf gewartet,
bis einer sein Passport eingibt und hat dann, vermute ich mal,
den Speicherinhalt von KeyPass abgegriffen.
Und man hat dann später die KeyPass-Files
auf einem Windows-Share gefunden.
Da lagen dann auf einem Windows-Share
Text-Dateien mit Amazon-Logins und sowas drin.
Ja, also das ist nicht so ohne Weiteres.
Wie habt ihr das gelöst?
Alle Dinge abgeschaltet, neu installiert.
Also ich hab's ja zum Glück gar nicht machen müssen.
So, und was wollte ich jetzt da?
Ich wollte aber irgendwie drauf raus.
Ja, und das kann dir mit einem Zettel nicht passieren.
Auch wenn man hier Zettel geschrieben hat, ja.
Das kann dir mit einem Zettel nicht passieren.
Wenn du einen Zettel hast und im Schrank liegen hast,
der hilft dir zwar nicht, wenn du illegale Sachen machst
und bei dir wird das Haus durchsucht.
Dann hast du aber meistens schon wirklich Scheiße gebaut,
wenn bei dir das Haus durchsucht wird, ja.
Aber gegen die 0815 Hexadudes hilft ein Zettel fast besser als ein Keypass.
Ja, also Zettel ist gut.
Zettel ist top Passwort-Manager.
Gibt's Passwort-Manager, die die Passwörter eingeben ohne...
Ja, es gibt für Keypass ein paar Browser-Erweiterungen,
die das machen können, aber letztendlich in irgendeiner Art und Weise
muss das ja immer in Arbeitsspeicher...
In irgendeiner Art und Weise muss das immer in Arbeitsspeicher.
Es muss vielleicht nicht in Clipboard speicher,
sondern in irgendeiner Art und Weise in Arbeitsspeicher.
Also gibt's auch Browser-Erweiterungen für Keypass für.
Aber letztendlich, es muss irgendwo unverschlüsselt im Rahmen landen.
Anders geht's gar nicht.
Das ist halt das, wo du es abgreifen kannst.
So, also gucken wir mal.
Der Felix hatte mal so eine komische Maus.
So eine super ergonomische.
Ich fand das ja äußerst gewöhnungsbedürftig,
hat mir nicht gefallen.
Warte mich ehrlich, was denn?
Was, was, wie, wo, hä?
Entschluss ist einfach.
Du musst den Salt wissen, du musst wissen,
was du für ein Passwort eingegeben hast
und welcher Algorithmus verwendet wird,
kannst du entschlüsseln.
Drei Sachen brauchst du.
Brauchst Passwort, Klartext, Salt und Verschlüsselungsalgorithmus,
dann kannst du den Kram, äh...
Also wenn es, wenn es eine Verschlüsselung ist,
nicht wenn es gehashed ist in irgendeiner Art und Weise,
ein hash ist keine Verschlüsselung, hash ist eine One-Way, äh,
One-Way-Funktion.
Also wenn ich was hashe, kann ich aus dem hash nie wieder
das Original rekonstruieren.
Wenn ich was verschlüssel, das ist ja gerade der Unterschied,
wenn ich was verschlüssel, dann kann ich mit einem Passwort
quasi aus dem verschlüsselten Text
den Klartext wieder herstellen, bei dem hash nicht.
Wie lang ist mein Masterpasswort?
Äh...
Ich glaube 25 Stellen oder so.
Irgendwie so über den Daumen gepeilt.
So, aber wir gucken jetzt mal wirklich ein bisschen Amazon.
Der MD5 kannst du auch nicht wirklich umkehren.
Du kannst halt MD5, ähm, im Voraus berechnen.
Das ist ja das, was, was viele schon gemacht haben.
Du kannst viel MD5 im Voraus berechnen.
Äh, ja, ich weiß, es gibt ein paar andere, es gibt noch ein paar Schwachstellen bei MD5.
Und, ähm, du kannst halt mittlerweile auch dadurch,
dass du mit Grafikkarten so schnell bist,
der Sache irgendwie noch auf die Spur kommen.
Aber für die so, nur nach 15 Sachen daheim,
da ist das MD5 eigentlich immer noch okay.
Aber wozu, wozu MD5, wenn man auch Shards 256 oder sowas verwenden kann?
Das ist eine äußerst gute Frage.
Ja klar, aber wie sollen die IT-Firmen an das Passwort kommen,
wenn es dort auf dem Server schon verschlüsselt liegt?
Wenn es gut gemacht ist und der einzig richtige Weg ist, gar nicht.
Gar nicht.
Jeder Service, der es dir erlaubt, dein Passwort zu recover
oder in irgendeiner Art und Weise, ähm,
verschlüsselte Dateien wiederherzustellen,
der hat sie nicht richtig verschlüsselt.
Verschlüsselung heißt, Passwort weg, Daten weg.
Ganz einfach.
Und das Endschlüssel muss kleinzeitig passieren.
Das Endschlüssel muss kleinzeitig passieren.
Also sprich, es wird bei dir, es wird bei dir lokal.
Mal angenommen, du hast jetzt irgendeinen Cloud-Dienst,
wo du Dateien hochlädst und die sagen,
hey, wir speichern das nur verschlüsselt.
Dann kriegst du eine Software von denen
oder vielleicht ist es ein Browser-Add-on oder eine Webseite
oder was auch immer.
Du klickst auf den Upload-Knopf oder du ziehst da eine Datei rein,
die du da hochladen willst.
Aber mega, mega mach ich das nicht.
Mega macht es ja so ähnlich zumindest.
Du gehst auf die Seite, ziehst deine Datei da rein,
die Datei wird lokal bei dir verschlüsselt,
hochgeladen und mega hat keine Ahnung, was bei ihnen liegt.
Und mega hat keine Ahnung, was bei ihnen liegt.
Also mega macht da noch ein paar mehr Tricks,
weil du kannst ja mit mega,
weil mega kannst du mit einem Link
dann die Sache auch einfach wieder entschlüsseln.
Aber mal angenommen, du hast jetzt sowas wie,
was gibt es denn eigentlich für Schlüssel?
Ich verwende das, ich verwende mein eigenes Zeug.
Keine Ahnung, aber wenn du einen Cloud-Dienst hast,
der sagt, sie verschlüsseln alles,
dann musst du das lokal verschlüsseln,
hochladen, runterladen auf einem anderen Rechner
und dort lokal wieder entschlüsseln.
Anders kann das nicht funktionieren.
Ja gut, bei Veracrypt ist es ja so,
aber Veracrypt geht halt nicht unbedingt über die Cloud,
weil Veracrypt, das ist übrigens auch der Nachteil,
wo wir gerade schon dabei sind, von Veracrypt Volumes,
Veracrypt Volumes sind ziemlich kacke für die Cloud,
weil Veracrypt Volumes sich bei kleinen Änderungen
oftmals viel ändern.
Das bedeutet, du änderst 5 Bites
in einem 5 GB großen Veracrypt Container
und am Ende sieht der quasi für jemand,
der das Ganze nur verschlüsselt sieht,
aus, als wäre die komplette Datei geändert.
Also sprich, du änderst ein Text-File
in deinem Veracrypt Container
und er lädt 5 GB wieder neu hoch,
weil er denkt, die Datei hat sich komplett geändert.
Das steht ja so nicht drinne.
Das ist ja grad der Witz dabei.
So wie ich das gelesen habe,
das steht da gar nicht so genau drinne.
Da steht einfach nur,
dass irgendwie die Möglichkeit geschaffen werden muss
oder sowas und die Firmen sagen halt,
das geht nicht.
Wir können es nicht nur halb verschlüsseln.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Wenn wir verschlüsseln,
dann wissen wir selber nicht, was drinne ist.
Aber so muss es ja eigentlich auch sein.
So muss es eigentlich sein.
Wenn was wirklich sinnvoll verschlüsselt ist,
dann weißt nur du, was drin ist,
beziehungsweise du musst doch nicht mal wissen,
was drin ist.
Du weißt, wie du drankommst.
Das ist das Wichtige.
Du brauchst dein Passwort.
Dort, wo du es hoch lädst,
die haben keine Ahnung, was da drin ist.
Die können das auch nicht rauskriegen,
wenn das ordentlich verschlüsselt ist.
Und wenn du dein Passwort verloren hast,
ist es vorbei.
Und die Frage, was mit Passwort-Resets ist,
ist im Prinzip das Gleiche.
Ein Anbieter, der dir dein Passwort resetten kann,
dass du wieder Zugriff auf deine verschlüsselten Daten bekommst,
da ist zumindest irgendwo eine Hintertür,
wie du wieder drankommen kannst.
Sonst können sie dir ein Passwort-Reset schicken.
Wie Passwort-Reset bei VeraCrypt funktioniert
oder bei Lux.
Die machen das ein bisschen anders.
Ich habe ja gesagt,
VeraCrypt verschlüsselt eure Festplatte
nicht wirklich mit dem Passwort,
was ihr eingegeben habt,
sondern mit random Keys,
die sie am Anfang der Platte und am Ende der Platte speichern.
Und diese Keys,
da kann man verschiedene Passwörter hinterlegen,
mit denen man die entschlüsseln kann.
Also sprich, man kann beispielsweise bei Lux geht es,
wie es bei VeraCrypt ist, weiß ich nicht.
Bei Lux kannst du zum Beispiel...
Lux ist quasi das VeraCrypt von Linux.
Bei Lux kannst du zum Beispiel
drei Passwörter hinterlegen oder so.
Kein Problem.
Da kannst du mit drei verschiedenen Passwörtern
deine Platte entschlüsseln.
Weil unter der Haube dieses Passwort nur dazu dient,
den eigentlichen Encryption-Key zu verschlüsseln.
Das hat nämlich den großen Vorteil,
wenn du dein Passwort änderst,
musst du nicht die komplette Festplatte re-encrypten.
Sonst, wenn die nämlich dein Passwort verwenden würden,
um deine komplette Festplatte zu verschlüsseln,
müsstest du jedes Mal, wenn du dein Passwort änderst,
deine komplette Festplatte entschlüsseln
und neu verschlüsseln.
Das dauert ja ewig.
Ja.
Das ist tatsächlich so, ja.
Ja, gut, die Leute checken das nicht.
Das wird ja auch absichtlich gemacht.
Es wird aber absichtlich nicht großartig breitgedreht,
es wird aber absichtlich so gemacht,
dass es kaum einer checkt.
Der Witz ist ja,
dass die, die das verabschieden, wahrscheinlich auch nicht checken.
Also ansonsten würden da nicht so komische Dinger drinstehen.
Das ist richtig.
Block-Device-Sync ist doof.
Genau, ich benutze KeyPass, aber ein Zettel ist auch okay.
Nur Noobs sagen, Zettel sind nicht gut.
Sag ich jetzt einfach mal.
Zettel sind vollkommen okay für Passwörter.
Es sei denn, du hast, es sei denn, es sei denn,
du bist jemand, der wirklich komische Dinger treibt
und eventuell mal die Polizei zu dir nach Hause kommt,
dann ist ein Zettel keine gute Idee.
Aber wenn du einfach nur jemand bist,
der nicht will, dass der Keylogger seine Passwörter abgreift,
dann ist ein Zettel eines der besten Sachen,
was du machen kannst.
Weil durch diese Barriere von Computer zu Offline-Zettel
kommt da kein Hacker-Man dran.
Vielleicht ein Passwort einzunacheinander mit einem Keylogger.
KeyPass, ich benutze KeyPass.
Ich benutze aber KeyPass hauptsächlich,
weil ich seit Jahren schon KeyPass verwendet.
Gar nicht.
Nur du kannst das.
Wenn du den verschlüsselnden Cloud-Dienst verwendest,
die das richtig machen,
dann werden die Daten bei dir lokal verschlüsselt,
verschlüsselt hochgeladen.
Der Anbieter hat keine Ahnung.
Und wenn du die Daten wieder haben willst,
dann lädst du dir die verschlüsselte,
den verschlüsselnden,
encrypteten Datei,
lädst du dir runter
und entschlüsselst die lokal bei dir wieder.
Der Schlüssel verlässt nie deinen Kopf quasi
oder deinen Passwort-Save
oder deinen lokalen Rechner.
Und wenn du das Passwort vergisst, hast du gelitten.
Wenn du das Passwort vergisst, hast du gelitten.
Du kannst das alles nur ändern,
wenn du deinen Passwort noch hast.
Also beispielsweise Veracrypt oder Lux,
wenn ich jetzt sage,
ich möchte meinen Passwort ändern,
wie ich mein System verschlüsselt habe,
dann geht das nur, wenn ich meinen Passwort noch weiß.
Wenn ich meinen Passwort nicht mehr weiß,
dann geht das nicht.
Das ist der Sinn von Verschlüsselung.
Wenn das Passwort weg ist,
sind die Daten weg.
Fertig.
Und nur so kann gut gescheite Verschlüsselung funktionieren.
Aber wir gucken jetzt mal echt bei Amazon.
Ich habe mich jetzt schon eine Stunde über alle möglichen Sachen
oder so ausgelassen.
Aber ihr wisst ja, ich bin
Meister im Sidetracked werden.
Exzellent.
Also bis jetzt war nur Müll dabei.
Da gibt es irgendwelche Super...
Da sollten sich die Schulen mal ein bisschen was von anschaffen hier.
HDMI auf VGA.
Das ist für die Ollen-Beamer, die die haben, bestimmt wunderbar.
Weil ich muss mal kurz gucken,
ob ich nicht irgendwelche Subs...
Oh hier.
Andreas X.
Subscribe Prime Gaming.
Was ist...
Was zum Teufel ist Prime Gaming?
Was ist Prime Gaming?
Ist das der kostenlose Prime Sub?
Ah, das ist der Prime Sub.
Ich wusste...
Mir fällt zum ersten Mal auf,
dass da Prime Gaming steht.
Weil in meinem anderen Browser steht nur Prime.
Und hier steht Prime Gaming.
Exzellent.
Danke schön für den Sub.
Was haben wir sonst noch hier?
Was habe ich übersehen?
Ich hoffe nix.
Äh...
Tsugatsatsango.
Für zwei Monate.
Danke schön für den Sub.
Exquisite Subscription.
Äh...
Timer und so sich wieder.
Ok, ne passt.
Ich glaube ich hab nix vergessen.
Ok jetzt gucken wir mal ein bisschen Amazon.
Also was haben wir hier?
Gedürzt.
Da sollte sich echt mal jede Schule
ein 50er Pack von kaufen,
dass sie ihre Ollen-Beamer verwenden können.
So, was haben wir sonst noch Schönes?
Äh...
Braucht kein Mensch, braucht kein Mensch.
Gibt's eigentlich schöne iPhone XR Hüllen
im Prime Cyber Monday Deal?
Braucht nämlich eine.
Die sind aber nicht schön.
Ach du große Kacke im Zebra Look.
Copper Bride Hülle, was ist das denn?
Schon was gefunden?
Ne.
Oh ja, Gänseblümchen, nice.
Wisst ihr an was mich das erinnert?
Das erinnert mich...
Das erinnert mich übelst an die Logitech Maus
mit den Beulen.
Kennt ihr noch...
Äh...
518 hieß das Ding?
Ne, MX518.
Die mit den Beulen?
Kennt ihr noch jemand?
Ja, Leopard und Zebra kommen
sie doch fast gleich aus.
Kennt ihr noch jemand die Beulen Maus?
Das war früher die Gaming Maus,
der schenkt schlechthin an Gaming Maus.
Mittlerweile ist die nicht mal so gut,
weil Sensor ziemlich sackt.
Außer der Refresh, der mag vielleicht ganz gut sein,
keine Ahnung.
Aber das war damals die beste Maus überhaupt.
Oh, das war's für mich hier, excellent.
Wobei...
Warum hat das Katzenohren, Alter?
Können die die Katzen...
Ich finde die Hülle so echt cool.
Aber ich will da keine Katzenohren oben dran haben.
The fuck?
Oh, das sieht billig aus.
Guck mal wie schlecht das ausgeschnitten ist.
Da haben die chinesischen Kinderarbeiter
nicht richtig ordentlich ausgeschnitten.
So, was haben wir sonst noch?
Ja, Logitech hat eine neue Version ausgebracht,
das ist jetzt aber auch schon ein bisschen älter.
Oh, ich werde gerade jebaited.
Ich werde gerade jebaited.
Ich habe irgendeine Message bekommen,
wo einer sagt, er gehört zu Twitch.
Da bin ich ja immer skeptisch.
Musste mal kurz überprüfen, ob das wirklich so ist.
Hm.
Okay, könnte wirklich echt sein.
Okay, könnte echt sein, ja.
Ey, da muss man vorsichtig sein, ja.
Chat-Message-Highlight-Tool.
Spannend, spannend.
Muss ich mir mal angucken.
Ich habe mir selbst so etwas gebastelt,
was Chats highlightet.
Ich müsste das mal ausprobieren.
Ich habe es aber bloß gerade nicht an.
Ich habe mir sowas ähnliches selbst gebastelt,
was denn die Messages highlightet.
Warum auch immer.
Frag mich nicht.
Das ist übelst unoptimiert hier mit dem Chat.
Ich weiß.
Ich habe es aber auf dem zweiten Bildschirm auf.
So.
So, gucken wir mal weiter.
Also, was haben wir denn hier Schönes noch?
Also, was haben wir denn noch?
Zeig mal da.
Nee, nee, nee, nicht Band.
Und auch nicht Monkratos.
Zum Glück, man weiß ja nie.
Man weiß ja nie.
Oh, oh, hier.
Huge, huge message.
Meine Lehrer haben mich gefragt,
wie man am besten ein Kabel vom Laptop zum Wipe...
Ach, okay, na gut.
Warum nicht?
Die wissen wahrscheinlich, du kennst dich aus.
Ja.
Habe ich denen gesagt, dass mein Vater...
Was?
Das ist Chebat, oder?
Das hast du denen nicht ernsthaft erzählt.
Das ist Chebat.
Also, also quasi.
So, wir müssen jetzt mal gucken,
ob da irgendwas dabei ist.
Ich wollte eigentlich, Leute...
Eigentlich wollte ich schon wieder weg sein.
Aber hat ja wieder nicht funktioniert, ey.
Okay, Handyhüllen gibt es nix, scheiße.
Sieht alles kacke aus.
Okay, schauen wir mal an.
Also, alles Mist, brauchen wir nicht.
Brauchen wir nicht, brauchen wir nicht.
Was ist das denn?
Ist es für die Corona-Proteste?
Was haben sie denn hier am Start?
Setke, guck mal.
Nee, ist das nicht?
Ja, nee.
S-G-O.
Ich habe irgendwie gerade Setke gelesen.
Frag mich nicht, wie oft...
Okay, das ist Schiemaske.
Alles klar, jetzt habe ich es auch kapiert.
Ihr wisst ja, das sind die Masken,
die auf den China-Kamera-Herstellern
immer als Einbrecher auf den Thumbnails sind.
Passt mal auf.
Moment.
Oh, die haben ja kein Bild vom Einbrecher drauf.
Ähm...
Ach, fuck.
Ich brauche immer ein...
Äh, Equation.
Haben immer so Dinger drauf.
Alter, jetzt, jetzt, wo ich sie suche,
finde ich es nicht hier.
Die haben auf diesen Bildern immer exakt
diese Typen mit Schiemasken drauf.
So was da.
Alter.
Warum?
Warum haben die jetzt...
Warum haben die keine Leute mit Schiemasken drauf?
Jetzt, wenn du sie suchst, findest du sie nicht.
Ja, so was hier, guck.
Aber das ist eine andere Maske.
Das sieht exakt wie die Schiemaske aus,
die die China-Typen immer haben.
Hier, so was.
So Leute sind da immer auf den Bildern drauf.
Aber der hat einfach nur Hoodie und Schalen um.
Das ist richtig Vorführeffekt.
Übrigens, Leute, das ist das, was ich meine,
was die Taktik bei Amazon ist.
Oder wo ich zumindest glaube,
Du musst dich durch so einen riesen Haufen Müll wühlen,
dass du am Ende, wenn du was findest,
ich hab's ja schon ein paar Mal gesagt,
dass, wenn du am Ende was findest,
was dir halbwegs gefällt, dass du es dann kaufst,
weil du schon so lange dich durch den Müll gewählt hast,
hast du keinen Ausgript.
Nee, hab ich nicht.
Ich hab Adblock, Adblock, Origin, Ublock, Ublock Origin
mit ein paar Custom-Regeln.
Das reicht.
Ich hatte früher, Firefox hatte ich immer einen Ausgript.
Aber leider kann man es nicht mehr gut verwenden seit...
also mittlerweile wieder, aber immer noch nicht so gut wie vorher,
seit Firefox 68, wo sie ihre Plug-in-RP geupdatet haben.
Seitdem ist NoScript nicht mehr so gut.
Ah, okay.
Ah, Twitch ist ja big brain, Alter.
Jetzt seh ich's ja auch.
Twitch-Mitarbeiter haben ja einen Mitarbeiter-Tag neben dem Bild.
Da hätt ich gar nicht nachgucken müssen, ob das echt ist.
Es gibt wohl irgendwie ein neues Chat-Highlighting-Tool.
Das ist praktisch.
Das guck ich mir später mal an.
Exzellent.
Zockst du eigentlich noch?
Ab und zu mal ein bisschen Path of Exile,
aber die League hab ich nicht gespielt.
Okay, also es ist ja wirklich nur Müll mit dabei.
Übrigens, ich glaub, die hol ich mir noch mal.
Welche Größe sind das?
Äh, Größe?
Ich weiß nicht, wie groß die sind.
Ah, hier.
Zehn Millimeter, also einen Zentimeter.
Ungefähr Daumennagel groß.
Ja, ich glaube, davon hol ich mir wirklich mal welche.
Ich claim mir das mal schnell.
Ach, fuck.
Ich kann mich ja hier nicht einloggen.
Okay, Blitzdeal ist gelaufen, ist vorbei.
Egal, scheiß drauf.
Aber davon, davon könnte ich tatsächlich noch einen Pack brauchen.
Weil ich mach das einfach auf dem zweiten Bildschirm.
Easy.
Oh, ich mach das einfach auf dem zweiten Bildschirm.
Accept.
Jawoll.
Zack.
Add.
Add to basket.
Bam.
So.
Zack.
Haben wir schon mal was.
Äh.
Meinungen zu Pros, die deine Privatsphäre schützen sollen.
Zum Beispiel Brave.
Ich hab mal Brave ne Weile verwendet.
Benutz ich nicht mehr.
Ich kann dir gar nicht mehr sagen, warum.
Da hat mich irgendwie nicht so überzeugt.
Ich benutze, auf Android benutze ich den hier.
Promite.
Das ist quasi ein Chrome.
Den sie ein bisschen entgoogelt haben.
Den verwende ich auf Android.
Der hat einen eingebauten Blocker.
Und ein paar andere Privacy Sachen.
Den find ich gut.
Brave ist irgendwie overrated.
Brauch man nicht.
So.
Taugt alles nix hier.
Brauch man net.
Ich fühl mich fast schon bedroht hier bei Amazon.
Und ich würd sagen, die Blitzdeals machen wir weg.
Aber Blitzdeals sind wirklich zum größten Teil Crap dabei.
What the fuck.
Äh.
Wofür benutzt du die Magneten?
Zum Beispiel.
Für ne.
Tür.
So ne.
So ne kleine.
Klapp.
Für die Tür, dass die zu bleibt.
Hab ich jetzt letztens welche verwendet.
Zum Aufhängen.
Von Sachen sind die ganz gut.
Äh.
Zum Positionieren.
Von.
Äh.
Beispielsweise ein Controller.
Und so sind die auch ganz gut.
Oh.
Oh Mist.
Ich seh grad die Katze hat mein.
Äh.
Temperatursensor den runter geschmissen.
Und die Ecke vom Display ist abgebrochen.
Ich wollte nämlich grad gucken, was für Temperatur ist.
Ich hab ja auf dem Schrank so ein selbst gebasteltes.
Ähm.
Klimaanlagensteuerungsding liegen mit nem Temperatursensor dran.
Funktioniert noch alles.
Steht auch 21,67 Grad drauf.
Aber die Ecke vom Display ist abgebrochen.
Aber das Display funktioniert noch.
Die hat es runter geschmissen.
Mir ist nämlich eingefallen.
Das hing am Kabel heute morgen unten.
Niemals Arturo WTF.
Allein schon.
Allein schon sowas zu schreiben ist ja schon kurz vor Timeout, Alter.
So.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch hier?
Lightning Deals.
Machen wir mal weg.
Kinder Lightning Deals ist Müll dabei.
Noch eins weg.
Brauchen wir nicht.
Okay.
Ich such mal nach wirklich ernsthaft was, was ich brauch.
Also ich bräuchte.
Ähm.
Silikon.
Klebeband.
Ich weiß nicht wie die Dinger genau heißen.
Sowas hier bräuchte ich.
Gibt es da irgendwas in Deals?
Natürlich nicht.
Äh.
Die sind tatsächlich ganz nice.
Aber ich brauch was dickeres.
Das gibt's net.
Wunderbar.
Kein Isolierband.
Nee.
Ich hab sowas richtig nicees mal gefunden.
Das benutze ich total, total gern.
Um irgendwelche Sachen wasserdicht, wasserdicht einzu, einzu, zu, zu rappen.
Es gibt so nen.
Äh.
Silikonband.
Selbst.
Nicht selbstklebend.
Ähm.
Sowas, sowas ähnliches wie das hier.
Sowas, sowas hier.
Das ist richtig nice.
Ähm.
Das ist doppelseitig.
Das machst du zusammen.
Das ist quasi.
Ähnlich wie nen Schrumpschlauch.
Nur ohne zu schrumpfen.
Das ist wasserdicht und klebt auf sich selbst.
Also.
Wenn man, wenn ich die Seite auf Deutsch hätte.
Würde da da stehen quasi sowas wie.
Äh.
Selbstverschweißen.
Natürlich wird verschweißt sich das nicht.
Das finde ich extrem praktisch.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das richtig weiß oder nicht.
Aber das ist wirklich nice.
Einfach drum gewickelt.
Das Ding ist wasserdicht zu.
Und es ist bombenfest.
Äh.
Deswegen kein normales Isolierband.
Ich brauch was, was beiseitig klebt.
Lass man das schön.
Und das, das Gute daran ist halt.
Das ist.
Das kann so ein bisschen stretchen.
Ein bisschen stretchen.
Das heißt, wenn du das.
Wenn du das ein bisschen ziehst.
Um was drumherum.
Wrapsst.
Und dann zusammen pappst.
Dann ist das richtig stramm und fest.
Und dann ist das richtig fest.
Und dann.
Aber.
sulfur.
Hä?
extrem sie link war übertreibt halt mal
16,5 meter ok 16,5 meter das ist eine ganz schön fette rolle glaube ich
ok gibt nichts was ich brauche also schauen wir mal bei nicht so sinnvollen sachen weiter
also der chat wieder der lowbrade chat gerade am start
oi chat so also leitenden dienst war einfach wenn ich leitenden dienst war müll
schauen wir ob es ordentliches werkzeug gibt hier exzellent gibt agro schrauber agro schrauber kann
man nie genug haben das aber ein 18 volt agro schrauber ich hab keine 18 volt agos hier
oh gucke mal ist der gsb der mit schlagfunktion ja hey das ist gar nicht übel ich glaube der deal
ist wirklich nicht schlecht es gibt die haben gsr und gsb willst du dir eigentlich cyberpunk holen
wahrscheinlich aber ich kann gleich sagen dass das vom setting ja nicht meins ist ja ja das
ist so ein hybrid aber der gsr den es normalerweise also den ohne der gsr da ist ein bisschen kürzer
hat aber kein schlagwerk drin und ich habe mir damals den gsr gekauft und ich habe schon ein
paar mal damit geliebäugelt oder ich habe das geliebäugelt 2 will ich mir nicht kaufen ist
bescheuern aber ich habe mir schon ein paar mal vielleicht wäre es gar nicht so schlecht
gewesen hätte ich mit schlagwerk gekauft weil ich habe damit jetzt auch schon ein paar löcher
gebohrt und es geht es geht ja auch ohne schlagwerk aber ich könnte mir vorstellen es geht ein
bisschen geschmeidiger das ist kein richtiger schlagschrauber das ist richtig das ist so ein
hybrid ding aber man glaubt gar nicht was kleine 12 volt akkuschrauber mittlerweile für power haben
vernünftiges werkzeug öffnet bosch ich weiß es nicht ob du damit sagen möchte dass es gut
oder schlecht ist dass es einer der besten 12 volt akkuschrauber den zu gibt finde ich
das ist richtig pop das ding gibt jetzt kommt jetzt nicht letzt jetzt kommt jetzt kommt
ein markita kommt nichts an ein ein bar mit kommt nur mit walkie oder sonst was an start ich
finde den ich finde den sehr nass rasti ja so ist es ja auch aber das finde ich gut also das ist
glaube ich echt kein schlechter deal was kostet der normalerweise so das kostet mal ein paar
geilzahlen zum vergleich was er normalerweise kostet ok der kostet überall so wenig lohnt
sich naja ok man spart vier euro man spart vier euro ja ach moment sind das ist alles die das
sind alles die mit zubehör das ist das sind alles die mit mit tasche ja fast vier euro ok also ich
habe genau den aber die gsr also den ohne schlagwerk dabei die ausschließt das set ist auch ganz ok
was da dabei ist des boras hat ist in der tasche drin war bei mir drin weiß ich ob hier mehr drin
ist ist einfach die tasche ausgepackt glaube also bei mir war das alles in der tasche drin deswegen
ist ja auch da die tasche dabei können wir gucken was jeder bei steht ok gucken wir mal
beispielsweise was die hier dazu sagen zur artikelbeschreibung
ne da ist anscheinend wirklich nichts dabei
die gute bohre ist es nicht aber man kann damit bohren und für ab und zu mal ein loch bohren
reicht es finde ich ich habe damit schon ein paar löcher gebohrt das funktioniert ohne
probleme und ich habe den ohne schlagfunktion na gut wenn das nur bei amazon mit zubehör ist
dann ist das angebot wirklich echt gut ja also wer kein wer kein 12 volt akkuschraube hat
dann ist das hier jetzt euer ding ja ach das ist die die amazon edition ja dann ist ja alles klar
gibt zwei augusti gibt es zwei augusti bei also bei meinem set gab es zwei augusti bei
wie viel wie viel augusti dabei zwei augusti schon praktisch zweimal hier zweimal zwei amper stunden
akkus ja aber nicht dass du trotzdem trotzdem vier euro billiger als bei den anderen unabhängig
davon ob das dabei ist wohlgemerkt ich habe mein set für 84 euro gekauft aber meiner ist auch der
ohne schlagfunktion ich bin wirklich super zufrieden damit das ding kann man echt empfehlen
und man glaubt gar nicht was was 12 volt akkuschrauber echt für power mittlerweile
haben ich kann mich auch dran erinnern ich hatte früher mal ein auch auch in den boston und da
konnte mit der hand anhalten das ding gut das war auch damals schon kackteil ja also wenn du den
versuchst mit der hand anzuhalten dann klebt die hand daran wie viel das ist eine gute frage wie
viel das hat hier ne moment wo ja ne 15 muss ich den test angucken ich habe das bei amazon was
zu resellen müsste mal gucken wie viel das hat zumindest kann man sagen ich habe den gleichen
plus ohne schlagfunktion ist wunderbar echt top was haben wir sonst auch für werkzeug
stellstdinger gut da brauche ich nun wirklich nix da habe ich meine knipper sammlung für die
übrigens kniepecks heißen aber jeder sagt die knippecks so was könnte ich tatsächlich
noch gebrauchen bräuchte gerade wenn ich mal sachen auspacken ich habe jetzt öfters gedacht ich
bräuchte man ordentliches messer manchmal mühe ich mich dann in der schere echt ab ob die dinger
sind auch gar nicht so übel schrauben wir brauchen auch nicht gut hälschen grenzen also
kann man mal rein reinschmeißen kann man bestimmt mal brauchen ok was gibt's sonst auch für tools
nix was was hat was hat was hat das mit tools zu tun was du hast bei amazon ein let's play
adventskalender gefunden what the fuck schick mal schick mal links die baro tech life war
tech life nicht chinesen klingt das klingt irgendwie extrem chinesisch tech life erkennt
auch nicht was es sein soll alter wenn man will dass ein zeug ab bricht nach dem ersten mal dann
kauft man sich sowas hier ok ist wieder nichts was von vorwarnen alter vorwarnen klingt ja fast so
gut wie cogeek formsealing tape brauchen sowas das ist so ein ding wo ich mir vorstellen könnte
wenn man es hat kann man das öfters mal verwenden nicht im stream öffnen ok
öffne ich nicht im stream sehbaro nein das ist glaube ich nicht das ist glaube ich nicht
das ist glaube ich kein tross es ist nicht tross ich sehe ich sehe da nix nackisches aber es
auch nichts spannendes irgendwie was man sich angucken müsste weil ich habe ich habe auch
als let's play gelesen mit let's play gar nichts zu tun die meine in dem fall mit let's play
das da so ich glaube das ist tatsächlich nicht verkehrt das kann man sich mal kann man sich
mal geben also lightning dealer muss auf der anderen seite wieder ran alles klar zack
ok so ist sonst irgendwas gescheites bei akrobat alles ist nicht so ein pdf so ein pdf ding
das sieht nicht nach pdf aus aber sie erinnert mich an pd an komische nervige pdf software was
was das was das ist dübel ist das ist das ein dübel der special big brain dübel oder was ist
das so weil ich werde dann nicht so hundertprozentig schlaut raus wenn ich ehrlich bin ja das ist
ohne das ist big brain dübel brauche ich nicht ich habe auch kaum was gekauft bisher bei black
friday ich dachte ja eigentlich der ganze black friday kram ist durch da kam heute amazon um die
eckertes haha die cyber monday ist auch noch am start oh ohohohoh monka smoke aller
uiuiuiuiui vor 50 euro weiß ich nicht die baro ich habe das nicht gelöscht das wurde entfernt das
Sebaro, das wurde gelöscht, das wurde gelöscht Sebaro, das E-Mode, aber ich kann einfach
ein anderes hinzufügen, ich kann einfach ein anderes hinzufügen von einem anderen
Channel, ach nee only available in, was ist denn da los, warum ist das, warum ist das
nicht da. Sebaro, da müssen wir später mal gucken, falls du das E-Mode irgendwo
findest auf BetterTwitchTV oder irgendwo, dann füge ich es wieder hinzu. Ich habe
jetzt nur eine andere Version gefunden, dort war das allerdings auf einen
speziellen Channel beschränkt. Das geht nicht, das ist beschränkt auf O-Zu-Gar-Chat.
Das kann ich nicht, kann ich nicht einbinden, das dort, aber das hier ist
dann wirklich MonkaSmoke, also wenn das nicht abfackelt, was wollen sie uns denn
hier für 15 Euro geben, also ein Lötkolb, aber immerhin, immerhin mit
Temperatureinstellung vermute ich mal, dass das eine Temperaturregelung ist, man
erkennt das nicht so wirklich gut, ehrlich gesagt, das könnten 200 Grad sein,
das könnten 350 Grad oder so sein, ich erkenne da nix.
Wer liest denn auch schon Titelchat? Aber der Rest ist wirklich ganz ganz billiges
Zeug, das ist nach allem mal verwenden ein Schäpp, so eine Pumpe ist tatsächlich
ganz nützlich, also was man damit macht, ist folgendes, so dass mal kurz kurz
erklären, man macht diesen, wie nennt man das, dieses Ding da rein, ja, da gibt es
einen Unterdruck, da geht dann Schwachsinn, nochmal von vorne, man macht das da rein,
dann hält man, dann macht man mit dem Lötkolben das Lötchen an einer Stelle
flüssig und dann hält man das dran und drückt da drauf, so und wenn man da drauf
drückt, da ist eine Feder drin, die zieht das dann raus und dann entsteht ein
Unterdruck da drin und dann kann man quasi flüssiges Lötzchen wegsaugen
damit mit so einer Pumpe, das heißt, hält man dann dran, dann macht man so, macht die Pumpe
und dann zieht es das Lötzchen weg. Kann man eigentlich noch bleihaltiges
Lötzchen kaufen? Klar, privat darf man das, das ist überhaupt kein Ding. Was ist so die
Standardmissung? 70, 30, 60, 40, ich weiß gar nicht, ich habe auch normales
Lötzchen mit, mit Blei, das, das fließt besser, kann man sich kaufen, überhaupt kein
Ding und wie bekommt man das dann aus der Pumpe? Das fällt meistens von der Leine
wieder raus, ansonsten kannst du bestimmt noch aufmachen, aber bei mir fällt das
eigentlich danach wieder von der Leine raus.
Wahrscheinlich kannst du es aufmachen, musst du es noch nie aufmachen. Also eine Pumpe ist
tatsächlich ganz nützlich, diesen Lötkolben hier würde ich ganz im Ernst,
naja, gut, ich meine wir hatten letztens ein Set, das war 15 Euro mit noch eine
Multimeter dabei. Müsst ihr nicht arbeiten Flo96? Also ich muss nicht arbeiten, ich weiß
nicht, wie es bei dir ausschaut. Ich habe Urlaub bis Januar.
Außerdem ist ja eher die Frage Flo96, müsstest du nicht vielleicht arbeiten?
Übrigens, hier, was auch ganz cool ist, wenn man einen Lötkolben haben will, den
man mobil verwenden kann, was richtig, was ich mir schon seit einer Weile holen
will, war es TS-18 oder TS-100, ob TS-100 was, war das der? Ich glaube so was hier, da bin ich
mir schon eine Weile am überlegen, ob ich mir sowas holen soll. Da kann man sogar
Customfirmen draufflaschen. Ihr wisst ja, ich flashe eh alles mit
Customfirmen und das ist jetzt ein Lötkolben, da kann man Customfirmen
flaschen. Den kannst du auch mit der Powerbank betreiben. Oder was, der TS-80?
Ich will auf jeden Fall den mit USB. Dann der, dann der, ich weiß nicht ganz sicher,
welcher, das ist der mit USB-C. Man kann sein Lötkolben übertakken, wenn du
eine Customfirma drauf hast. Da kannst du mit Alexa den Lötkolben steuern,
oh jetzt habe ich den Namen gesagt. Jetzt ist wahrscheinlich bei ganz vielen wieder
angesprungen. Kennst du noch nicht den SH-72-Lötkolben? Nee, ist das, ist das auch so ein
Ding? Ah, guck mal hier, Porgas, was ist das? Aber, okay. Das sieht ein bisschen billiger
aus als der andere. Also zumindest, wenn es um Werkzeug geht, kennt ihr ja meine
Philosophie. Ich kaufe mir mittlerweile lieber ein bisschen besseres Zeug und
bisschen teureres Zeug und dafür hast du auch quasi mehr Spaß mit. Und bei
billigem China-Elektronik-Zeug, kennt ihr auch meine Philosophie, da kaufe ich mir
meistens nicht eins oder mindestens drei, weil da macht man ganz gerne mal was von
kaputt. Und gerade wenn man aus China bestellt, lohnt sich das auch, weil der
Versand aus China ist nicht viel, nicht viel höher. Wo wir gerade bei China sind,
müssen wir gleich mal gucken, was die Chinesen noch am Start haben. Und, weil
das unter dem letzten YouTube-Video auch oft geschrieben wurde, man kann nach wie
vor ohne Probleme ab nächstem Jahr auch in China bestellen, weil es ist so. Ich gebe
jetzt einfach mal irgendwas ein. Sales, alles Sales, letztes Mal war das noch billiger.
Letztes Mal hat es so 5 Euro gekostet, da war es auch schon Sale. Okay, nehmen wir mal irgendwie
ESP Node, NodeMCU.
Nehmen wir mal beispielsweise eine NodeMCU. Nehmen wir uns irgendwas hier. Keine Ahnung.
Wo sind die denn? Nehmen wir mal sowas hier beispielsweise. So, was kennst du den Toolpack ES-12-1-Schraubentreer?
Ja, wenn es dieser Schraubentreer ist mit dem Motor, dann kenne ich den und den fände ich kacke,
wo ich ihn gesehen habe. So, also, ab nächstem Jahr gibt es keine freie Grenze mehr für Zoll.
Genau, hier. Wo steht es denn? Ja, also hier sind gemäß, ne? Also, ich habe hier ein
gemäß, ne? Also, ich weiß gar nicht, ob das jetzt verabschiedet wurde, aber genau, bisher
war das so. Es gab die Regelung, dass du irgendwie mit bis 22 Euro musstest du nichts bezahlen,
das hat den Zoll auch nicht interessiert. Dann gab es noch irgendwie von hier bis 150
und ab 150 war es dann irgendwie anders. Also, du musstest quasi gar nichts bezahlen, dann
musstest du nur Mehrwertsteuer bezahlen und dann musstest du Mehrwertsteuer und Zoll bezahlen.
Und jetzt gibt es diese Freigrenze nicht mehr und das denken viele jetzt, oh Mist, man kann
auch China nichts mehr bestellen, aber das stimmt gar nicht. Zobel16, Twitch Prime, danke
schön für den Sub. Huge Subscription. Ich bin heute irgendwie nicht so gut im Gucken,
sorry Leute, falls ich irgendwas übersehe mit Subs. Ich schau mal kurz in mein Dashboard
rein, ich bin heute ein bisschen zu vertieft in meinem Gelaber. Ja, danke schön Zobel16,
wen haben wir sonst noch? Swarmhost stinkt, hat mit Prime abonniert von 17 Minuten, danke
schön für den Sub. Exquisite Name, exquisite Sub. Den Rest habe ich schon. Annie, du musst
fragen, Roffel, nicht Annie Subbers, du musst fragen Annie Gifters, wenn du was gegiftet
haben willst. Heinrich Neumodal, danke schön für den Sub. Huge Subscription. So, ok, aber
kommen wir mal zu dieser ganzen China, ups, zu dieser ganzen China Geschichte zurück.
So, und nachdem quasi diese unter 22 Euro Grenze wegfällt, sagen jetzt viele, oh nee,
man kann gar nichts mehr aus China erstellen. Aber, das ist falsch. Erstens, ich überlege
gerade mit was ich anfange. Große Porsche-Champ-Einlage. Also, fangen wir mal so an, erstens haben
viele, das stimmt, viele China, das ist auch der Grund, warum sie das wahrscheinlich machen,
haben viele China-Händler getrickst. Also, du hast dann keine Ahnung für 150 Euro Elektronik-Kleinteile
in China bestellt und die haben draufgeschrieben 7,50 Euro. Und das konnte keiner so wirklich
richtig bewerten, ja. Hast du jetzt da ein Packen voll mit China-Crap, hat es jetzt 7,50
Euro oder 150 Euro gekostet. Außerdem, wenn die Dokumente gefaked sind, ja. Gut, dir
als Besteller kann eh nix passieren, der Händler ist im Arsch, theoretisch, aber das ist dem
Händler in China ja egal. So, und jetzt fällt das weg. Ich kann das schon verstehen, warum
man das gemacht hat. Ich finde das auch irgendwie böse oder so. Ich bin denen jetzt auch nicht
böse das zu machen, weil da wurde wirklich verdammt viel getrickst. Aber, man kann trotzdem
noch aus China bestellen, weil man geht einfach hierhin und sagt, okay, exzellent. Also, mal
gucken, ob der Shop das jetzt hier anbietet. Und wir gehen auf EU-Priority-Line. Wir bestellen
hier unsere 10 NodeMCUs, bestellen wir jetzt für 50 Dollar ungefähr. So, und jetzt kommt
der Trick. Übrigens, das kann sein, dass das jetzt auch schon kommt, ja. Wenn man die Euro
eher 1,50 mehr ausgibt, was man bei dem Preis von 50 Dollar mal machen kann. Und EU-Priority-Line,
übrigens das ist Banggood Express, das geht auch. Diese Sachen sind nur diese, was hiervon
betroffen ist, sind diese ganzen ultra lahmen Billig-Versand-Sachen. Also keine Ahnung,
zum Beispiel das, was früher AliExpress Standard war. So, wenn man früher AliExpress Standard
bestellt hat. So, Machina. Genau, wenn du sowas hier bestellt hast. So, das ist, ihr seht's,
das ist ewig unterwegs. 5. Februar, 1. Januar, das ist ewig unterwegs. So, und das kommt
über den Schiff sonst wie hin. Und dann ist die Frage, wie der Händler das macht. Und
ob das ganze greift. Denn, äh, wo hab ich's hier. Diese Sache greift nur für Sachen,
die aus nicht-EU-Ländern kommen. Also das bedeutet, wenn die Chinesen das direkt irgendwie
hier reinfahren wollen nach Hamburg oder keine Ahnung. Aber AliExpress ist ja nicht
doof. AliExpress macht so gut wie jetzt alles schon über die Niederlande. Und teilweise
in PostNL. Das heißt, die gehen dann in die Niederlande und von dort geht das Paket an
euch. Das bedeutet, das Paket kommt nicht aus dem Ausland. So, und je nachdem, wie die
das kennzeichnen, ist halt die Frage, wie gut das klappt oder wie gut das nicht klappt.
Wo es auf jeden Fall funktioniert, ist, wenn der EU-Priority-Line macht. Das kann zwei
Auswirkungen haben. Entweder der China-Händler verschickt das Paket an Niederlande, Spanien,
Italien oder sonst wo, irgendein EU-Land. Und von dort, ich weiß nicht, ob sie dort
ein neues Etikett draufkleben oder so, keine Ahnung. Und von dort geht das Ganze dann weiter
zu euch. So, und nachdem dann die Sendung quasi offiziell aus Spanien, Italien, Niederlande
kommt, juckt das keine Sau. Eigentlich eine gute Taktik, ja. So, was auch eine Möglichkeit
ist, dass es einfach direkt aus dem EU-Warenlager losgeschickt wird. Viele China-Händler haben
mittlerweile auch EU-Warenlager, so wie man hier sieht. Man kann ja hier aus Polen bestellen.
Guck mal, in Polen ist es billiger als aus China. Dafür ist der Versand ein bisschen
teurer. Russland liefert nicht nach Deutschland, Spanien, Italien, Frankreich. Also sprich,
ich kann quasi in Polen, Frankreich, Italien günstiger bestellen, schon what the fuck,
als in China. So, ich sag mal, nehmen wir das polnische EU-Lager und bestellen da, aha,
aha, da muss man jetzt mal gucken, ob sich das lohnt, weil in China bleibt es billig,
in China bleibt es billig, der L19 Euro. Muss man mal gucken, ob sich das ganze lohnt,
weil, wenn man so 12 Euro versandt, okay, aber auf der anderen Seite bezahlst du halt
weniger, wenn du nämlich sowas hier bei Amazon kaufst, so ein Board, kostet es 7 Euro oder
sowas, 8,50. Also, nee, Moment, das ist doch, hier kostet es 8,50, also das kann sich durchaus
lohnen. Wieso ist der Versand aus Polen teurer als aus China? Weil der in China auf irgendeinem
Containerschiff anschippert, über drei Monate oder so. Voraussichtlich 1. Januar, also das
ist jetzt erstmal, das ist jetzt erstmal einen Monat auf dem Schiff, bis es bei dir ankommt,
ja. Das ist billiger. Und Polen ist halt Land. Wahrscheinlich einfach DHL. Mal gucken, ob
die noch vor, mal gucken, ob die noch vor, guck mal, die kommen sogar noch vor Weihnachten
an, wenn du es aus Frankreich bestellt, aus Italien, Januar, Spanien, 18, also, man kann
aus den USA bestellen, sehr sinnvoll. Also, wenn man bestellt aus Spanien oder Frankreich,
bekommt man sogar bis vor Weihnachten. Und das, was Dicky5 schreibt, kommt auch noch
dabei, genau, da habe ich gar nichts dran gedacht. China subventioniert auch übelst
den Export und die Versandgeschichten. Wisst ihr, was ich mich dann frage? Wir bezahlen
ja auch Entwicklungshilfe nach China. Ich frage mich, ob die quasi mit unserer Entwicklungshilfe
den Versand zu uns subventionieren. Das wäre ja mal excellent big brain, oder? So, nach
dem Motto, wir brauchen Geld, wir haben ganz viele arme Leute noch in ländlichen Regionen,
gib Entwicklungshilfe und dann nehmen sie die Entwicklungshilfe und geben sich den armen
Leuten, sondern subventionieren den Versand nach Deutschland. Das wäre der richtige China
move, Alter. Ich kann mir das alles vorstellen. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir noch viele Entwicklungshilfe
nach China bezahlen. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie viel man da noch bezahlen kann. Aha, wie
viel? Kann man mal machen. Kann man sich mal gönnen. 630 kann man mal machen. Easy money,
easy life. Ich meine, die sollten vielleicht mal in Deutschland Entwicklungshilfe bezahlen
für den Internetausbau. Was? Sehe ich das richtig? Die Türkei bekommt 3,6 Milliarden
Entwicklungshilfen. Dafür sind die aber sehr unkooperativ in letzter Zeit. Na gut, was
auch immer. Na gut, zumindest, das wäre noch mal richtig big brain move. Man nimmt einfach
die 630 Milliarden Entwicklungshilfe und subventioniert den Versand nach Deutschland. Ich wusste gar
nicht, dass 3,6 Milliarden, Alter, aber nicht von uns alleine, oder? Ich habe mir das noch
nie so genau angeguckt. Nee, das ist insgesamt, insgesamt. Alter, was ist das für? Das ist
ja brutals viel Kohle, ey. Was haben die gemacht mit 9 Milliarden? Weil man hätte ja mal vielleicht
dafür sorgen können, dass die Leute besseres Leben führen, aber nee, man hat sich lieber
gegenseitig umgebracht. Big brain move, Alter. Dafür sind das gut, gut, gut investierte 9
Milliarden. Top. Naja, next level brain, ja. So wenig sind 9 Milliarden, nicht? So wenig
sind 9 Milliarden. Natürlich, bei unserem, wie heißt, Jahres-Dingsbums-Produkt-Gramm ist
es nicht viel, aber bei dem bin ich vergessen. Ich weiß nicht, was so das Protoinlandsprodukt
von Syrien normalerweise ist. Guck mal, 40 Milliarden, die haben 40 Milliarden Protoinlandsprodukt
und bekommen 9 Milliarden. Das ist ein ganz schön großer Anteil. Gut, ich kenne mich
mit der Sache Null aus. Ich habe da absolut keinen Plan von. Ich sehe jetzt die Zahlen
zum ersten Mal. Ich kann das absolut nicht einordnen, was da läuft, aber das ist anteilmäßig
schon ganz schön viel. 2007, ja geil. Danach haben sie angefangen, sich gegenseitig den
Kopf wegzuspallern. Top. Beste Investition überhaupt da. Ja, gut. Schauen wir mal weiter.
Da ist nichts dabei hier. Outstanding Move. Was machst du da immer mit den Links? Meinst
du das hier? Ich kopiere eine 1 in die Zwischenablage. Das ist richtiger Pro-Gamer-Move. Das können
nur ehemalige Overwatch-Profis machen. Wenn ihr schon immer mal wissen wollt, was braucht
man, um Pro-Gamer zu werden, der erste Schritt ist 1er kopieren. Der Richie ist auch am starten.
1er kopieren. Das ist schon mal das Allerwichtigste. Wenn ihr das drauf habt, dann ist zumindest
mal Global Elite sicher. Da müsst ihr gar nichts mehr großartig machen für. Was ist
das? Einfach eine schwarze Kiste? Warum ist das schwarz? Ah, das ist für die Gartenmöbel.
Okay, braucht kein Mensch. Wer hat schon Gartenmöbel? Das würde ja heißen, man sitzt im Garten
Möbel. Vielleicht sogar noch in der Sonne. Wo kommen wir denn da hin? Übrigens exzellent
Bildbearbeitungs-Sachen hier auch. Guckt euch das mal an. Da hat der Fiver Photoshop-Mann-Frau,
weiß man ja nicht, ähm, die Photoshop-Innen haben bei Fiverr das wirklich, oh dieser Schnee,
oh der Schnee ist ja richtig gut. Der Schnee, wie in echt. Ich kanns kaum erkennen. Also,
das ist doppelt RTX On. Gott, sieht das scheiße aus, ey. Das andere sieht auch nicht viel
besser aus, ja. Aber gerade dieser Schnee, das sieht wirklich kacke aus. Und hier diese
Lensflare-Effekt. Ich mein, wo kommt der Lensflare überhaupt her? Hier ist überhaupt keine
Sonne zu sehen. Ach von da. Ja klar, die Sonne ist in Wirklichkeit im Gemüsebeet. Gegenüber
beim Nachbar, die Sonne. Natürlich. Dieses Regentropfen. Okay, das ist wirklich mies,
das Teil. Der könnte mir Thumbnails machen, der Kerl. Oder die Photoshop-Innen. Die sollen
mal rausrücken, wer ihr Designer ist. Das kostet dann auch nicht so viel, wenn ihr mir Thumbnails
macht. Und vielleicht sind schlechte Thumbnails besser als gute Thumbnails. Weil gute Thumbnails
haben so viele Leute auf YouTube mittlerweile, weil man einfach schlechte macht. Die müssen
dann aber so richtig schlecht sein. So richtig miembar schlecht. Hey, was ist das für ein
Video? Hey, was? Moment, what? Ist eine MSI RTX 208 Super ihr Geld wert? Äh, nee. Nicht
mehr. Achso, du willst die einen kaufen. Du willst die einen kaufen, oder? Willst du
die verkaufen? Du willst die kaufen. Ich glaub, jetzt hab ich's verstanden. Also vor ner Weile
haben alle ihre RTX 280 aus dem Fenster geschmissen für ein Apple und ein Ei. Weil, äh, die
rumgeraged haben, weil die neue 30, 70 oder so besser ist und die Hälfte kostet. Also
ist fraglich, ob es ihr Geld wert ist, je nachdem, was es gerade kostet. Lassen sich
die Fire Tablets mit Stock Android flashen? Also, nachdem ihr ja vorhin schon ein offizieller
von Twitch war, weiß ich nicht, ob ich das erzählen darf, aber ich kann das ja mal umschreiben.
Es kommt auf das Alter des Tablets an und auf den Typ des Tablets. Und dann würd ich
einfach mal googeln danach, ob das geht. Bei manchen geht's, bei manchen geht's nicht.
Bei den ganz neuen stehen die Chancen eher schlecht, bei den bisschen älteren Modellen
stehen die Chancen gut. Und, ähm, dann ist auch noch die Frage, ob's 7 oder 10, warte,
was gibt's? Fire HD 7 und 10? Gibt's auch ein 8? Gibt's ein Fire HD 8? Pass auf. Moment,
hab ich, hab ich sogar ein 8er? Warte mal. Hab ich vielleicht doch ein 8er und kein 7er?
Bei mir drüben im Bett liegen? Muss ich mal kurz gucken. Jetzt ist's doch mal. Früher
hätt ich das gewusst. Früher, früher, zu Zeiten, wo ich noch GameStar abonniert hat
und solche Dinger, ich, also, das ist schon ganz lange her, da konnte ich euch wirklich
Taktraten und Gedöns von allen Geräten sagen, von jeder CPU, die aktuell ist und ich wusste
auch ganz genau, was ich für Hardware-Specs hab. Aber jetzt, 20 Jahre später, hab ich
keine Ahnung mehr. Hatten wir das Smash-Pro-Theme nicht schon? Ich hab, oh Leute, ich hab euch
wisst, dass ich hab kein Fire HD 7, ich hab nur ein Fire HD 8. Also so'n Teil hab ich
da. So, also, ich scroll jetzt nur mal kurz hier, nee, nee, nee, neunzehn Seiten, guck
mir da nicht an, stopp. Was war denn das eben? Erinnert mal, was war denn das? Äh, wo ist
das hin? Das, was war denn das? Irgendein Set mit, ach, Schrauben und Unterlebe, pff,
da hab ich genug. Alter, die Musik, die Musik hier, exquisite. Ah, yes. Pipe and Wine.
Exzellent. Das ist das Smash-Theme. Oh, guck mal, Gosund. Da sind sie ja wieder. Was haben
die hier am Start? Vier Stück für 35. Das erscheint mir sogar recht okay, weil Gosund,
ich hab jetzt schon ein paar Sachen von Gosund gekauft, weil die nehmen es mit Firmware-Updates
nicht so genau. Ich hab jetzt insgesamt vier Gosund doppelte Steckdosenleisten und eine
Gosund Steckdose, äh, was entlame ich denn? Äh, vier so doppelte Steckdosen und eine
Gosund Steckdosenleiste und alles hat sich noch vor eins, zwei Wochen ohne Probleme flashen
lassen, wireless, ohne aufschrauben zu müssen. So. Das heißt, die nehmen das nicht so ernst.
Guck mal, die, die flashen, die flashen immer, die, die nehmen es nicht so ernst mit Firmware-Updaten
bei Gosund. Und das, glaube ich, ist sogar ganz okay. 35 Euro für vier Stück. Allerdings
finde ich die anderen besser, diese Doppel, Doppelstecker-Dinger. Die gab es heute auch
im Angebot für 15.19. Also, da muss ich sagen, ich hab, also, ich kann persönlich sagen,
das lässt sich flashen, das Ding. Und das Ding lässt sich flashen. Hab ich beides noch
vor einer Woche gemacht. Und wir haben sogar im Stream mal eine aufgemacht, wo es nicht
richtig funktioniert hat. Und konnten es ohne Probleme dann von Hand flashen. Aber muss
man nicht, weil die sich eigentlich, denke ich, war fast, also der hier auf jeden Fall,
also drei von vier, die ich hatte, haben sich auch flashen lassen übers WLAN. Und wahrscheinlich,
und wahrscheinlich hätte es, wenn ich es mal richtig gemacht hätte, die andere auch
flashen lassen, die ich im Stream aufgeschraubt habe. Aber, ich mein, dafür haben wir einen
nice Stream gehabt, wo wir das probieren können. Wofür geflashed? Gute Frage. Die Frage kommt
nämlich immer. Und deswegen weiß ich auch schon ganz gut, was ich daraus sagen kann.
Also, der Nachteil dieser Steckdosen ist, die gehen nur über die offiziellen, meistens,
meistens, Ausnahmen bestätigen die Regel, aber meistens, die gehen meistens nur über
die offizielle App vom Hersteller. Was schonmal ziemlich doof ist, wenn man quasi ein Heimautomatisierungssystem
hat und das da einbauen will und man kann es nur über eine offizielle App vom Smartphone
machen. Das ist schonmal doof. Das zweite ist, was für mich absolutes K.O.-Kriterium
ist, warum ich sie nicht mit der Original-Firmware verwende. Die Dinger brauchen zwingend Cloud-Verbindungen
nach China. Das sind ja zwei Sachen in einem, die mir auf den Keks gehen. Erstens Cloud-Verbindungen,
zweitens auch noch Cloud-Verbindungen nach China. Ich hab prinzipiell alles offline,
was bei mir im Smartphone ist. Also alles funktioniert ohne irgendwie Internet-Anbindungen
in irgendeine China-Cloud. Wenn was Online-Services benutzt und mein Internet geht nicht, dann
funktioniert es zwar nicht, aber für so einfache Sachen wie eine Steckdose will ich nicht,
dass wenn mein Internet ausfällt, dass die Steckdose nicht mehr funktioniert. Das ist
ja total, total hängen geblieben. Und dass diese Sache gar nicht so weit hergeholt ist,
hatten wir erst vor ein paar Tagen gesehen. Da hatte Amazon bei AWS einen Ausfall. AWS
ist diese Amazon Cloud-Service-Gedöns. Und da hatten einige Leute Probleme, ihren Staubsauger
zu verwenden. Muss ich jetzt mal vorstellen. Amazon hat einen Ausfall, du kannst seine Wohnung
nicht mehr staubsaugen. Und ihr Thermostat. Also sprich, manche Leute haben dann dadurch,
dass Amazon einen Ausfall hatte, hatten dann quasi eine dreckige Wohnung. Muss ich mal
übertrieben zu sagen. Eine dreckige Wohnung. Eine kalte, dreckige Wohnung, ja. Ging aber
schnell vorbei. Gibt es ein neues Gesetz, oder hast du mit den China-Bestellungen? Ja,
ab 1.01.2021 gibt es keine Freigrenzen mehr beim Zoll. Aber das ist kein Problem, du
musst einfach EU-Priority-Line bestellen, dann hast du kein Problem. Dann wird es über
den EU-Land verschickt. Dann schicken es die Chinesen zum Beispiel nach Italien, Spanien,
Niederlande, von dort weiter und dann kostet es auch keinen Zoll. So, genau. Deswegen,
wenn man die flasht, und da kam eben auch die Frage, was bedeutet geflasht? Flaschen
bedeutet, du tauscht die Software aus, mit denen die Dingern ausgeliefert werden. Also
die Steckdose selbst, die hat ja keine Ahnung von W-Lan und wenn du in eine App auf ein
und ausschalten trickst und so. Da ist eine Steckdose drin, mit ein paar Relays, unten
im Controller. Dieser Controller hat eine Firmware drauf, also quasi das Betriebssystem
von diesem Controller oder halt die Software, mit dem dieser Controller läuft. Und diese
Software kannst du austauschen, und das nennt man halt flashen. Wahrscheinlich, weil das
meistens auch Flash-Speicher ist. Ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, woher das Wort
flashen kommt. Da könnte man einen Command draus machen, das ist ne gute Idee. Mod-Check,
Leute, Mod-Check. Haben wir hier einen Mod da, der das gerade machen kann? War da Sebaro
nicht eben noch? Da hab ich doch irgendwo gesehen gerade. Ach, wann kommt da, da ist
er doch, der Sebaro. Wann kommt da ein Hetzer-Placement? Ich hab mit Hetzer nichts abgesprochen
oder so. Command, für das was ich gerade erklärt hab, was flashen bedeutet, vor 30 Sekunden
oder so. Das wäre äußerst, wenn du das machen könntest. Ja, genau, und deswegen
flashen man die Dinger. Ich flash die Sachen immer hiermit. Find ich am besten, wenn man
nicht großartig programmieren will. Top. Und danach sieht das so aus, ich zeig euch
mal ein Beispiel. Dann habt ihr so ein Menü, das ist übrigens noch eine ganz alte Version,
ich glaube ich sollte mal was neueres zeigen. Hab ich noch irgendwas neueres hier drin?
Nee. Okay, das ist das einzige, was ich jetzt gerade sehe. So, da habt ihr quasi ein Web-Interface
für die Steckdose, wo ihr dann die einzelnen Steckdosen mitschalten könnt. Ohne China
Cloud oder alles. Und natürlich ist es auch genauso doof, wenn man jedes Mal auf das
Web-Interface muss. Deswegen kann man diese Sachen wunderbar in seine Heimautomatisierung
anbinden. Die können so ziemlich alle gängigen Heimautomatisierungs-Sachen. Also MQTT ist
eigentlich mit das gängigste. Du kannst HTTP-Request hinschrinken, du kannst MQTT-Messages hinschrinken.
Und für alle, die Home Assistant verwenden, gibt es jetzt was Neues. Also ist das, was
ich für Heimautomatisierungen verwende. Gibt es jetzt was Neues. Es gibt ne neue Tasmota-Integration,
die alles komplett automatisch macht, wenn man Tasmota geflasht hat. Das ging vorher
schon, aber mittlerweile gibt es sogar ne offizielle Extension für Home Assistant. Da kannst du
deine Tasmota-Geräte quasi mit einem Klick einbinden. Und die sünden sich dann in deinen
Home Assistant und du kannst alles dort drüber auslesen. Also sprich Stromverbrauch von Geräten,
du kannst Steckdosen ein- und ausschalten, du kannst gucken, wenn ein Temperatursensor
ist, was für eine Temperatur. Also alles, was das Gerät kann. Eigentlich ziemlich neiße
Sache. So und deswegen werden die Dinger immer geflasht. Und die Sache ist halt die, wenn
man versucht, die Sachen zu flaschen, die Hersteller sind da meistens nicht so scharf
drauf, dass man das flaschen muss. Äh, dass man das flaschen kann. Weil die Hersteller
wollen ja, dass du ihren eigenen Krams verwendest. Wobei man da halt auch wieder sagen muss,
dass sie unterschiedliche Interessen haben. Also, es sind ja meistens zwei verschiedene
Parteien da involviert. Es gibt einmal den, der diese Steckdose wirklich herstellt in
China. Dann gibt es den, der dort sein Logo draufdruckt, nachdem er sich die Steckdose
gekauft hat. Und dann gibt es vielleicht noch irgendeinen, der es hier vertreibt oder so.
Das wird ja was anderes. Aber bei China-Produkten ist es ganz oft so, dass das, was drauf steht,
nicht der Hersteller ist. Also sprich, deswegen sieht man auch so viele China-Geräte, die
exakt gleich aussehen. Also diese Steckdose hier. Diese Steckdose hier. Oder noch, noch
ein viel besseres Beispiel. Ich zeige euch mal eine andere Steckdose. Wartet mal. Ähm.
Ach fuck, wie hieß das Ding? Ähm. Ich muss mal kurz in meine Amazon-Bestellhistorie gucken.
Amazon-Bestellhistorie. Hier. Die da. Die da. Die da. Die da. Die da. Die da. Die da.
So. Diese Dinger. Die hier laufen unter, was weiß ich, Amazon-Dings. Diese Teile gibt
es von mindestens zehn verschiedenen Herstellern, sehen exakt so aus, haben nur ein anderes
Logo drauf. Also das heißt, daran sieht man, es gibt einmal den China-Hersteller, der diese
Steckdosen baut. Und es gibt einmal die Typen, die ihre Logos draufdrucken. Der Hersteller,
der diese Dinger baut, der hat kein Interesse dran, das zu verbieten, dass man Custom-Firmware
drauf machen kann. Super Sebaro. Poggers. Huge Modding. Ähm. Der Hersteller, der diese
Steckdosen herstellt, der hat kein Interesse dran, das zu verbieten, dass die Leute Custom-Firmware
flashen. Weil unterm Strich verkauft er mehr, wenn die Leute Custom-Firmware flashen können.
Wer keinen Bock darauf hat, dass Custom-Firmware geflasht werden kann, sind diese Hersteller,
die da ihr Logo draufdrucken. Weil die wollen, dass man ihre Kack-Apps verwendet und im Zweifelsfall
auch Daten abgreifen und gucken, wie die User sich verhalten und so was. Also die wollen
das nicht. Das heißt, es ist ein kleiner Interessen-Konflikt, der da besteht. Deswegen sind die Chancen
relativ gut, dass diese ganzen China-Geräte, öhm, dass diese ganzen China-Geräte oftmals
auch 1-2 Jahre nachdem es Firmware-Updates gibt, die die eigentlichen Lücken gefixt
haben, dass man sie so ohne weiteres flashen kann, dass die immer noch die alte Firmware
drauf haben. Weil die Hersteller, die juckt das nicht. Die Einzigen, die das juckt, sind
die, die da ihr Logo draufmachen. Und Gosund scheint es nicht zu jucken, weil bei Gosund
konnte ich bisher alles flashen. Weil der Unterschied ist nämlich der, wenn die eine
neue gepatchte Firmware-Version haben, dann kann ich es nicht mehr hiermit konvertieren.
Hiermit ist es total einfach, so eine China-Stecklose zu flashen. Wir brauchen Raspberry Pi, die
Software drauf und kann das übers WLAN flashen und alles ist gut. Wenn ihr das neueste Firmware-Update
habt, dann muss man aufschrauben. Und aufschrauben, ich sag dazu nur, kurz raussuchen, wenn es
um das Thema Aufschrauben von Steckdosen geht, dann sage ich dazu nur, habt ihr gesehen wie
ich es verbogen habe, dann sage ich nur, dass ihr dazu wenn es ums Aufmachen von Steckdosen
geht. Das Aufmachen von China Steckdosen. Es funktioniert nicht. Also die ging wirklich
kacke auf. Pass mal auf, jetzt kommt es gleich. Ich will jetzt eigentlich, ach Mist, ich verbiege
zumindest das Ding jetzt. Ich verbiege das Ding jetzt. So und daran sieht man, es ist
viel einfacher, wenn man diese Steckdosen übers WLAN flashen kann als wenn man die lokal
aufschrauben muss. Ey die Steckdosen waren wirklich eklig aufzubekommen. Jetzt weiß ich
wie es funktioniert, das ist total einfach. Jetzt würde ich die in 20 Minuten aufmachen,
flashen und zumachen wieder. Guck mal, was ich da vorgeklappt habe. Naja. So, also wahrscheinlich
kann man die flashen. Das ist eigentlich das worauf ich raus, rauf wollte. Scheinbar nicht
mehr flashbar. Ohhh. Das ist aber scheiße. Wenn das nicht mehr geht zu flashen. Kann
man die hier noch flashen? Welche sind denn, was haben, was sind denn das für welche?
Das sind, steht da irgendeine, ähm, Nummer? Was das für welche sind? Irgendwie EP2. Das
sind die, die sich nicht mehr flashen lassen, ja. Ah. Zumindest alles, was ich bisher von
Gursund hat ansflaschen lassen. Außer das eine, was ich aufgeschraubt habe, das hat
ich wahrscheinlich auch flaschen lassen. Äh, was verbraucht die smarte Steckdose denn
ungefähr ohne, dass ein Gerät angeschlossen ist? Das ist eine sehr gute Frage, weil ich
glaube viele Leute verbinden damit, dass diese Dinger quasi so, so rum eidelmäßig viel,
äh, viel Strom verbrauchen. Verbrauchen sie nicht. Also der ESP2866, was da drin ist,
der ist der Microcontroller, der wird wahrscheinlich, also der Controller selber läuft mit 3,3
Volt und braucht 100 milliampere. Also kannst du ja mal ausrechnen, 3,3 mal 0,1, also 0,3,
jetzt muss ich ja nicht ausrechnen, also der braucht 0,33 Watt. So, natürlich ist es in
Wirklichkeit wahrscheinlich ein Ticken mehr, das muss noch, na, von 230 Volt runter auf
3,3 und so, aber sag mal mal so, du bist locker unter, aber absolut locker unter einem Watt,
was das braucht. Also sowas weit, weit weg von, äh, das ist nix im Endeffekt, was das
braucht. Stellst du ein Weihnachtsbaum auf? Ja, ich werde mir dieses Jahr zum ersten Mal
seit, glaube, 2013 wieder einen richtigen Weihnachtsbaum kaufen. Machs gut, C-Bau.
Und da ist mir aufgefallen, dass Weihnachtsbäume mittlerweile saumäßig teuer geworden sind.
Wo habe ich noch mal ein Bauhaus oder so? Ich hab irgendwo im Online-Online-Dings mal
geguckt, ähm, das ist übelst teuer, der Kram. Hier, nehmen wir mal ein künstlicher Weihnachtsbaum.
Alter. Ich mein, 67 Euro für einen Weihnachtsbaum. Schon. Ordentlich. Gut, der ist auch ziemlich
groß. Fahr doch in den Wald und schlag dir einen selbst, also erstens darf man wahrscheinlich
nicht einfach in den Wald fahren und sich da irgendwelche Bäume abhauen, zumal es auch
schwierig ist. Du brauchst ja irgendeinen Kleinen, der da irgendwo am Start ist, äh,
und außerdem hab ich keinen Bock selbst zu machen. Zumindest ist der Kram ziemlich
teuer. So, ich scroll jetzt mal hier kurz weiter durch. Was ist hier? Das Dübel-Set. Exzellent.
Da wird heftig gedübelt. Mach mal alles nett. Bienen aber vieler an und ist billiger. Ja,
vielleicht mach ich das. Vielleicht mach ich das auch. Okay, hier haben wir wieder
billige China-Zeug. Mal gucken. Äh. Okay, ich glaube, das ist eine der hässlichsten
und gleichzeitig wahrscheinlich billigsten Crimzang, die ich je gesehen hab. Und, okay,
das ist dieser 0-15-billig-Netzwerk-Tester, den jeder schon mal hatte. Okay, nee, braucht
wirklich keiner. So, was gibt's denn sonst noch? Langweilig. Gib bitte wirklich ernsthaft
nur Müll. Lötzen hab ich noch genug. Brauchen wir nicht. Big Brain, 10 Euro Multimeter,
was wahrscheinlich sonst was misst. Aber diese China-Multimeter-Dinger, jetzt, ich hab da
schon ein paar Tests gesehen, die scheinen mir doch zum größten Teil ein bisschen besser
als ihr Ruf zu sein. Wie läuft's mit den LED-Strips? Richtig gut. Ist alles fertig jetzt. Guck
hier, Post Image. Äh, wo hab ich denn den letzten? Ja, Chat, ich hab letztens, History,
History. Ich hab doch den aktuellen LED-Strip-Stand letztens gepostet. Post Image. Wer da vielleicht?
Ah, da. Exzellent, guck mal. Ich hab extra die Punkte unterschiedlich hell gemacht, das
man sieht. Ich hab jetzt, ähm, ich hab jetzt Alu-Leisten gekauft, mit so, ähm, so nem
Milchklar, milchigen Plastik-Diffuser davor. Und dann hab ich das abgeschnitten. Also hab
ich abgemessen, abgeschnitten. Und jetzt hab ich's genau, passgenau fürs Fenster. Ich
kann meine Browser-Historie zeigen, überhaupt kein Problem. Und warum kann ich meine Browser-Historie
zeigen? Weil ich einen extra Browser hab, nur fürs Streamsorn, wo überhaupt nichts
drin passieren kann. Oh, ich zeig euch nicht, das ist nur eine normale, normale Browser-Historie,
wünsche ich euch im Leben, da zeigen, Chat. Da kann der Chat noch so. Vergessts. So, ähm,
so sieht's aus mit den LEDs. Und, ihr müsst ja mal zugeben, das sieht um ein Vielfaches
besser aus, als die erste Installation, die ich hatte, wo ich einfach mal testweise die
LED-Streifen an das Fenster gepappt hab. Ah, hier unten muss noch die Kiste zugemacht
werden. Hier liegt ne Kiste, wo das dann alles reinkommt. Ja. Viel besser. So, die Seite
machen wir jetzt noch durch, irgendwie ist da wieder nix dabei. Noch irgendwie, hey, ist
das nicht das billige China-Multimeter, was ich mir auch gekauft hab? Ich glaube schon.
Exzellent. Reicht, reicht für das, was ich machen will, aber ich hab jetzt ein paar
mal mit dem Gedanken gespielt, ob ich mir nicht schonmal ein besseres, ordentliches,
gutes Multimeter kaufen sollte. Was ist das? Schleifsteine, oder was? Nee. Hä? Doch, oder?
Ah, ja. Was ist das? Monkartos. Kann man die Geflächtenstecklosen eigentlich per App
steuern, oder wie läuft das? Jaja. Du kannst die entweder über den Browser steuern, hab
ich dir grad hier gezeigt. Du kannst die entweder über den Browser steuern, hier, und dementsprechend
kannst du die auch über jedes Smartphone steuern, weil du kannst dann mit deinem Smartphone
einfach auf die Adresse gehen, oder du bindest die in deine Heimautomatisierung ein, und
die hat ja dann eine App. Also ich benutze Home Assistant, zeige euch mal die offizielle
Home Assistant Demo, weil ich mein Home Assistant nicht zeigen will, dann lieg ich
wieder so viel. Das sieht dann ungefähr so aus. Das ist jetzt so eine Beispielseite
von denen. Ja, und dann hast du dann hier einen Knopf für Checkdose an und aus. Und
das gibt es auch als Smartphone App. Benutzt du privat auch Chromium? Ich hab so ziemlich
alles an Browser Marschall installiert gehabt. Aber Chromium verwende ich auch so. Also ich
hab aktuell Chromium installiert. Chrome, Firefox, Vivaldi, Edge gezwungenermaßen.
Was hältst du von Fritz Deckt? Kann ich dir noch nicht sagen Flo96, ich hab mir jetzt
zum ausprobieren, aber ich hab ehrlich gesagt gar nicht vor das zu benutzen. Ich hab mir
also zum ausprobieren so einen Fritz Thermostat mal bestellt. So eins hier. Wie gesagt, ich
hab nicht vor den Krams zu benutzen, weil ich brauch nicht noch ein Wireless Ding was
ich integriere. Ich mein ich hab jetzt, ich hab Wi-Fi Sachen in der Heimautomatisierung,
ich hab Zigbee Sachen in der Heimautomatisierung, ich hab SeaWave Sachen in der Heimautomatisierung.
Das ist unbedingt noch, ach ne und ich hab noch RF433, also die normalen olle Funk Sachen
für die Rollos drinne. Also ob ich da jetzt noch ne fünfte Funk Technologie drin brauche,
weiß ich nicht. Aber ich hab mir mal eins bestellt, weil ich mir genau die gleiche Frage
gestellt hab, ob diese AVM Geschichte was taugt. Deswegen hab ich mir auch eins bestellt,
das liegt hinter mir im Karton. Was genau hast du es für Rollos? Oh fuck. Irgendwelche,
also die die ich steuere, das sind so Plastik Schalusinen, so dünne. Oh wie heißt der Hersteller
irgendwas mit S am Anfang glaube ich? Sompfie oder so? Gibt's sowas? Sowas hier? Ja sowas,
sowas. Genau. Ja ich hab da auch so nen hässlichen Knopf hier dafür. Ich hab da so nen hässlichen
Knopf. So und das ist ganz normales RF433MHz und ich hab mir nen RF433USB Adapter gekauft
und da kann ich jetzt die Dinger ohne die Knöpfe steuern. Also ich hab mir für meine
Heimautomatisierung so nen Senderempfänger gekauft für diese Frequenz von denen und
da brauchte man dann so spezielle Codes, wie man sich irgendwie runterladen muss, ich krieg
das gar nicht mehr richtig zusammen und dann konnte man das dem beibringen. Nee, das geht
nicht. Klingt erstmal easy, wenn man ne Fernbildung hat kann man die Signale quasi abfangen und
kopieren kann man nicht, weil das sind Rolling Codes. Und Rolling Codes ist, ich bin mir
nicht sicher ob so ne Art Verschlüsselung ist für Infrarot oder RF. Rolling Codes zumindest
ändern sich die Sachen, wenn man den Knopf drückt. Also wenn man den Knopf drückt sendet
er nicht immer das gleiche. Oh und den Senderempfänger den ich mir gekauft hab, der kann
diese Zombie Rolling Codes. Also allein schon, dass sowas wie der verschlüsselt ist. Wobei
auf der anderen Seite, das ist sogar ganz gut, dass das verschlüsselt ist, sonst könnten
Leute von der Straße aus Rollen hoch und runter machen. So und zumindest die konnte ich dann
einbinden da drin. Ja und dann hab ich mir noch was anderes gekauft. Das hab ich aber
schon ne Weile und noch nie verwendet. Ich hab mir so nen Stick gekauft für Duo Fernroller
Motoren. Für so nen Teil da, so nen billiger, den kleinsten den es gab, weil ich den mal
ausprobieren wollte. Irgendwie sowas hier. Weil ich den mal ausprobieren wollte und da
gibt es auf GitHub ne Python API wo man quasi diesen offiziellen Hersteller Stick auch mit
nicht offizieller Hersteller Software verwenden kann. Ich hab mir, wie gesagt, ich hab mir
schon viel unnützten technischen Kram gekauft, unter anderem auch bei irgendwelchen Black
Friday Sales, Cyber Monday Sales, die ich habe einfach weil es mich interessiert hat
wie es funktioniert. Nicht so sehr, weil ich es wirklich verwenden will. Weil da sich
das lohnt, müsste ich quasi jeden Roller mit so nem Teil ausstatten. Ich hab hier mindestens
mal 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, irgendwie 8, 9 Rollen oder sowas. Da müsste ich nochmal tausend
Euro ausgeben. Nur für Roller-Dinger. Ne, ne, das muss nicht sein. So oft mach ich die
Rollen nicht hoch und runter. Wobei, easy Sub-Money, ne? Wobei, da fällt mir wieder ein, ich krieg
ja nur die Hälfte von ab, also ist es doch gar nicht so viel. Ne, das lohnt sich nicht,
das lohnt sich nicht. So, also wie gesagt, die Seite, die Seite, ne, Subgoals und sowas.
Ich, ich hab echt, ich bin jemand, der überhaupt nicht gut Subs geiern kann. Es gibt andere,
die haben das richtig gut drauf, die können richtig smoothen Sellout machen. Die Sellouten
quasi den ganzen Stream über und die Leute gehen ab wie sonst was. Ich, ich kann das
nicht gescheit, ich bin kein guter Sellout-Mann. Warum machst du die letzte Ziffer im Link
immer weg? Gib mal Ausrufezeichen 1 ein im Chat, da gibt's eine Erklärung zu. Ausgeschrieben
1. Also die Erklärung ist unterm Strich, weil ich sie nicht mehr alle hab. So, ähm, oh
hier ist nix dabei. Oh, die sehen gut, die Dinger. Äh, so, so, äh, weiß gar nicht,
wie die auf Deutsch heißen, die Dinger. Äh, wie nennt man das? Wie heißt denn sowas auf
Deutsch? Tufenbohrer. Ist wirklich Tufenbohrer. Tufenbohrer. Okay, ähm, die sind wirklich
praktisch, da hab ich mir auch mal so ein Set gekauft, das ist nicht, glaub nicht das
hier, die sind wirklich praktisch, wenn man zum Beispiel in Gehäuse Löcher machen will
die, die quasi schön weich sind, also schön eben und gut ausschauen oder auch in 3D-Drucke
und sowas, da sind diese Sachen wirklich Gold wert. Da kriegt man schöne, gleichmäßige,
nicht ausgefranzte, abgerundete Löcher. Das ist gut. Danach braucht man so ein Kabeldurchführungs-Ding,
dass man verschraubt auf beiden Seiten und das Ding wasserdicht zu. Du-du-du-du-du. Gibt's
dafür Custom-Firmware? Der Super-Rollo? Custom-Firmware für den Super-Rollo? Also, irgendwie, mal wieder
kaum was dabei. Das hat mich nix großartig angesprochen. Ich scroll mal kurz durch, was
die noch bei Smart Home haben und dann gucken wir mal kurz bei den Chinesen, ob sich da
irgendwas lohnt. Hast du Urlaub oder Homeoffice? Ich hab jetzt Urlaub, ich hab schon Urlaub
seit dem 18. bis Januar und davor hatte ich seit März Homeoffice. Ist Homeoffice in Apple
Exclusive oder kompletter? Hat mit Apple nichts zu tun. Gar nichts. Ist nicht HomeKit. HomeKit
ist Apple. Home Assistant ist komplett Open Source auf GitHub und du kannst das entweder
im Browser verwenden, du kannst dir die PWA installieren oder du kannst dir jeweils die
Companion App installieren auf iOS oder Android. Also Home Assistant selbst installierst du
allerdings am besten auf irgendeiner Linux-Kiste. Auf Windows würde ich nicht verwenden. Ich
glaube, Windows ist mittlerweile gar nicht mehr in allen Konfigurationen supported. Warum
so lange Urlaub? Ja, weil ich so viel Urlaub hab. Unicorn Salami? Ja, ich finde da auch
kaum was. Wie gesagt, meine Theorie ist ja eh, dass die einfach ganz viel Müll den Leuten
entgegenschmeißen, dass man dann das Gefühl hat, dass man ein gutes Gefühl hat, wenn man
doch noch irgendwas findet. Ok, also was gibt's denn heut bei Smart Home? Gibt's da irgendwas
Sinnvolles? Ok, Staubsauger-Roboter hab ich. Brauche ich nicht, hab ich schon zwei. Ich
hab einen ollen wenig smarten Eufy 11. Den kann man nur mit Infrarot, Fake Infrarot Fernbedienung
losschicken. Dafür ist er klein und kommt unter den Sofa, unter den Schrank oder sonst.
Und dann hab ich einen Roborock S50. Den Roborock S50 hab ich natürlich, ihr kennt mich Leute,
hab ich natürlich auch mit Custom-Firmware geflasht. Und jetzt kann ich per Browser
auf meinen Staubsauger-Roboter und den rumkommandieren, ja. Wettrennen fahren. Ein Roborock S50,
Roborock S50 hab ich. Den da. Und für mich war der ausschlaggebende Grund, dass man
Custom-Firmware drauf machen kann und dass ich keine China-Cloud brauche. So. Übrigens,
was auch cool ist, wo wir gerade bei Staubsauger sind. Kurz mein Lilux-VM anmachen. Hast du
den Roborock S50 im Angebot geholt? Ja. Ich hab den, mal gucken was er aktuell kostet.
Ich glaube ich hab 290 Euro für bezahlt, was damals wirklich, S5 und S50 übrigens
das gleiche, ein super Angebot war. Okay, gibt's grad gar nicht. Die gibt's grad gar
nicht. Du verstehst nicht warum er sich einen Staubsauger-Roboter holt. Ja, weil er staubsaugern
kann, ohne dass du selbst staubsaugern musst. Ich dachte auch nicht, dass es sinnvoll ist,
muss ich dir ehrlich sagen. Ich hab auch am Anfang gedacht, total sinnlose Spielerei.
Und als ich den dann in meinem Angebot für 290 gefunden hab und mich mal schlau gemacht
hab, dass man Custom-Firmware drauf machen kann und alles möglich, hab ich mir gedacht,
weißt du was, kauf's dir einfach mal und guck's dir an und ich muss sagen, ich find das unglaublich
praktisch mittlerweile. Gerade im Wohnzimmer für die ganzen Katzenhaare, das Ding fährt
einfach los, wenn ich schnell da bin, dockt sich wieder an und ich leere das Ding mal aus
und gut ist. Übrigens, was auch cool ist und was kaum jemand mit seinem Staubsauger-Roboter
kann, hast du einen Snipe mit Cell-Force. Ja, mittlerweile schon. Wie kommst du denn
darauf Chillfreak? Seit einer Woche, seitdem wir uns das mal hier im Stream angeguckt haben,
hab ich mir jetzt eins angelegt und hab angefangen meine Sensoren und Controller drin zu erfassen,
dass ich die besser finde. So Leute, Bäm. SSH Login auf dem Staubsauger. Ich weiß, dass
jetzt ein Leak kommt, es kommt immer ein Leak am Anfang, aber damit könnt ihr nichts anfangen,
ihr seid bei mir im internen W-Laden drinne. Guck mal, SSH Login auf dem Staubsauger-Roboter.
Also, welcher Staubsauger hat denn schon einen root SSH Login? Und man sieht da drauf, auf
dem Staubsauger läuft ein Ubuntu 14.04. Erstmal Docker drauf installieren. Also, man kann,
man kann theoretisch Sachen nachinstallieren. Das ist ein ganz normales Ubuntu 14.04, aber
ich sag euch mal ganz ehrlich, ich trau der Sache nicht, das Betriebssystem vom Roboter
so viel zu ändern. So viel Platz ist da nicht drauf, das stimmt, aber es geht, es geht eigentlich,
also man hat doch, man hat doch noch ein bisschen Platz. Guck mal, mein 1,3G, da kann man schon
ein bisschen was installieren. Könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern? Wir haben noch, wir haben
noch auf dem Roboter mal mein Paket, oh Mist, ich hab grad mein Headset runtergeschmissen,
also mein Verlängerungsteil vom Headset runtergeschmissen. So, ich muss das mal wieder entwirren, das
Kabel ist total verknotet. Das Kabel ist eigentlich 3 Meter lang und jetzt ist es irgendwie 20
Zentimeter. So, ähm, was wollt ich jetzt sagen? Wir haben ja mal ein Paket-Tracker-Software
mal probiert, auf dem Staubsauger-Roboter auszuführen, hat funktioniert. Es war ein
.NET Core-Programm, draufkopiert, gestartet und ich konnte meine eigene Software auf meinem
Staubsauger-Roboter laufen lassen. Hat funktioniert. Ja, aber der hat schon einen Staubsauger mit
SSH-Login. So, ich wollte aber Smart Home mal kurz durchscrollen, also nix, nix, nix,
nix, nix, jede menge. Plink. Also wer sich sowas kauft, äh, ne, geh mal fort. Die versuchen
ihr mittlerweile alle irgendwelche Abos unter zu jubeln, ne, so nach dem Motto, ja, kannst
die Security-Kamera unserer von uns kaufen, aber lokal speichern, oder irgendwelche Features
lokal verändigen. Das kannst du natürlich nicht! Das geht nur über unsere Cloud und
das geht dann auch nur mit einem Monats-Abo. Wofür nützt du Snipeit daheim? Also hier
die testinstallation was mir noch was man hier noch gesehen hat wo ich mal ausprobieren habe ich
habe das jetzt installiert für meine ganzen kleinen technikgeschichten also ich habe ich
kann es dir ja mal zeigen wenn du willst muss mal kurz gucken dass ich da nix drin stehen
habe was ich nicht will dass man das sieht ich habe da noch nicht so viel drin ja ja
ne kann man kann man zeigen sieht man so was habe ich da zum beispiel drin stehen
guck excellent passport so was steht da zum beispiel drin ja also wie gesagt ich habe
erst angefangen damit zeug zeug zeug zu erfassen das steht zum beispiel drin dass ich hier die
led strip eine rolle sk 6 3 1 2 rgb wie pleck habe ich in fach 1 liegen und zwar genau eins stück
schelle 1l habe ich jetzt neu bekommen habe ich fünf stück habe ich noch fünf habe ich noch
vier titico t display boards so was da ich versuchte jetzt nach und nach meine ganzen
kleinen technik sachen rein zu kriegen weil ich habe mittlerweile das problem ich habe so
viel technik krams am start das sind ja allein ich habe jetzt hier ich habe ich habe die letzten
tage übelst aufgeräumt ich habe gefühlt tonnenweise amazon verpackung weggeschmissen
und so was ich habe jetzt immer noch fünf sechs kartons voll mit technik krams mit so
klein scheiß den ich mir auf der zeit bestellt habe und das muss da alles rein weil ansonsten
finde ich nix ich finde nix mehr ja das war ich da das tool an sich ist maßlos oversized für
meine verhältnisse und 90 prozent der features werde ich gar nicht verwenden
trollo maz sagt mein vater hat sich so ein teil gekauft als im angebot war ich weiß gar nicht
aber was ich das jetzt bezieht du meinst so ein roborock die dinger sind richtig nice
gesagt dann flasht flasht das mal deinem vater eine blink kamera oh nee er die dinger
sind richtig richtig mies also es will dir eh jeder einen abo aufschwätzen aktuell alle alle
wollen sie dass du irgendwie also für dinger die normalerweise selbstverständlich sein sollten
auch dass sie lokal funktionieren wollen sie heute abos haben ja hast eine kamera lokal speichern
gibt es nicht du hast eine türkische sprechanlage lokal verwenden den hier geht nur mit unserer
cloud und nur mit abo wie du willst lokales backup machen geht plus cloud backup mit abo
also richtig richtig hängen geblieben deswegen ist bei mir spartan mäßig alles nur lokal außer
halt die sachen die online sein müssen wie zum beispiel meine location tracking vom handy wo
ich wo ich dann quasi gucken kann man heim automatisieren feststellen kann wo ich gerade
bin ob ich vielleicht umheimlich bin oder so das muss natürlich über übers internet gehen
weil ich mein mein handy ist ja nicht daheim wenn ich unterwegs bin was handy mithab ist ja
logisch wenn ich gerade in der bahn sitzt dann muss das natürlich übers internet die die position
schicken aber ansonsten alles nur lokal deswegen lege ich auch so viel wert drauf dass wenn ich
was kaufe gerade diesen china kram hier dass ich das flaschen kann mit custom software wo ich weiß
dass das lokal funktioniert dazu habe ich noch ein extra iot wlan wo quasi geräte nirgends wohin
dürfen nicht ins internet dürfen das einzige was gerät in meinem iot wlan machen dürfen ist ntp
sich zeit abrufen das war es nichts sonst nichts da darf nichts rein nichts raus aus dem wlan
das einzige was ist es der zugriff auf diese geräte von meiner heim automatisierung ist erlaubt aber
weil ansonsten ich ich traue da keinem hersteller ganz ehrlich ich traue da weder den chinesen noch
irgendwelchen weiß camps oder sonst was das ist alles alles hardware wo ich keine ahnung
was sie eigentlich im hintergrund macht und noch schlimmer sie kann von heute auf morgen
nicht mehr funktionieren weil der hersteller keinen bock hat philips you nicht philips you doch
philips you philips you auch die haben auch mal alte hubs unbrauchbar gepatcht aber das beste
beispiel dafür ist tp link tp link hat letzten sind firmware update verteilt wo die lokale der
lokale zugriff einfach abgeschaltet wurde sie haben sich raus geredet mit ja security oder haben
die leute da gesessen scheiße geht nicht mehr oder dann hat tp link gesagt aber ihr könnt ja uns
geklaut verwenden also was die aktion sollte weiß man jetzt ja mittlerweile nachdem das shitstorm
so groß war haben sie gesagt ja ok vielleicht entwickeln wir doch wieder eine firma mit der
man lokal drauf zugreifen kann und wer uns anschreibt der kriegt auch das downgrade und
blau und so aber aber nur weil die leute sich wahnsinnig aufgeregt haben so du bist halt auf
gedei und verderben deinem jeweiligen cloud anbieter ausgeliefert und wenn du jetzt sag mal
mal du geräte von 20 verschiedenen herstellern hast was echt nicht viel ist es gibt ja schon
verschieden es gibt ja 20 verschiedene recht verbreitete geräte geräte kategorien für
heim automatisierungsgeschichten und dann der eine oder andere hersteller sich überlegt
ich gehe jetzt bleibt oder ich verkaufe das ordnet es wird eingestellt zum beispiel nest
ist ja mittlerweile google und nest hat von heute auf morgen auch gesagt ach nee zugriff
auf das nestsystem das gibt es nicht mehr also du zeigst du konntest dann je nachdem was du
dir zu hause für eine automatisierung gebaut hast du konntest dann einfach ein thermostat
nicht mehr verwenden weil ich gedacht habe aber gewusst mehr wollen wir nicht und natürlich haben
die auch gesagt ja moment wenn du jetzt natürlich unsere google apps dafür verwendest dann
funktioniert das noch aber will ich mich wirklich davon abhängig machen auf gut wetter mit
irgendwelchen china herstellern deswegen bei mir ist das alles lokal und eine möglichkeit auch
direkt mit custom firmen wo ich weiß dass das nicht entweder nach china funkt in die usa funkt
an bauen sie wohin funkt oder geschweige denn irgendwelche updates die funktionen ausschalten
bekommt am besten gleich kannst du im firmen drauf und ruhe ist wieso hast du eigentlich
linux in einer form laufen beziehungsweise kein dual boot und geben verhielung als mehr
us weil ich sachen mache die unter linux nicht gehen nicht gescheit gehen also mein ganzes
video bearbeitungs audio bearbeitungs und audio mit foto thumbnail funktioniert nicht gescheit
unter linux zumindest nicht mit der software mit der ich mich einigermaßen auskenne und mit
gimp fange ich erst gar nicht an so also ich mache halt viele sachen unter winos die winos
only oder hauptsächlich bin aus only oder nur gut richtig gut so unter winos funktionieren
und dual boot ist mir zu anstrengend deswegen also ja macht man die ganze gaming geschichte
außen vor ja es geht zwar mittlerweile viel unter linux was gaming angeht aber spätestens
wenn man aktuelle multiplayer sachen spielen will die anti cheat haben dann ist die chance
doch ja höher dass es nicht geht als dass es geht und deswegen habe ich mir gedacht nachdem
ich zu faul bin für dual boot und dual boot nervig ist zumal ich die sachen ja auch mehr
oder weniger parallel mache ich mache einfach host windows und vm linux weil alles was ich
auf linux mache lässt sich wunderbar nahezu in native geschwindigkeit unter linux machen
in der vm und ich kann alles was ich unter winos machen will native mit native geschwindigkeit
unter winos machen also für mich ist es das optimale set up eine frage an alle oft thema
was könnt ihr bestätigen dass dvina ehrlich gesagt ich habe davon absolut keinen plan
aber nachdem beide techniken das digital an den monitor übertragen wüsste ich nicht
warum es einen unterschied zwischen dve und hdmi geben sollte es sei denn ein kabel ist
kaputt und dann hast du halt diese typischen digital übertragungsgeschichten du hast halt
dann nicht etwa gerausche wie mit einem halb kaputten kabel als das analog war sondern du
hast dann halt gar kein bild oder halt komplett bildaussetzer also ich wüsste nicht warum
die qualität qualität irgendwie anders sein sollte weil das was da übertragen wird die
bildinformationen werden bei beiden digital übertragen und die bildinformation selbst
sind bei beiden die gleichen ja ich habe erst bei mir angefangen hier mit ja klar wenn du
wenn du noch wenn du noch das analoge in dvi verwendest dann schon aber das macht ja keiner
ich habe jetzt bei mir angefangen mit rgb beleuchtung ach nee du meinst nie da kann
ich dir nichts zu sagen elgato key light ist diese streaming kamerade nee da kann ich
dir nichts zu sagen das ist die streaming kamera oder ja nee keine ahnung da war ich
nichts zu so generell heimautomatisierung rgb beleuchtung bin ich gerade dabei aber
zu dieser streaming kamera keine ahnung so ich wollte doch hier noch schnell die heimautomatisierung
steels durch scrollen leute bei the way ich wollte glaube ich schon vor zwei stunden weg
sein ja nein nicht ganz vor eineinhalb stunden aber scheiß drauf wir jetzt ist jetzt ist
eh zu spät jetzt kann ich euch da bleiben klappt dein rgb streiten jetzt auch mit dem
kleineren controller ja würde er ich hätte dem mal den flash komplett löschen müssen
dann funktioniert ich habe jetzt aber auch einen anderen controller ich habe jetzt einen
ollen esp 2866 genommen einfach weil ich davon noch so viele habe und das dafür locker reicht
kannst du eine wifi karte oder exis nee also die mikrotik singer sind alle linux based
hast aber keinen zugriff auf linux drunter ich habe ich habe die ich habe nur noch unify
access point mittlerweile ja die sind zwar nicht linux oder sind glaube ich schon linux
mäßig unten drunter aber du hast da keinen zugriff drauf aber unify dinger sind echt
ok sind halt leider auch bissl teuer ehrlich gesagt hast du ein mikrofon arm ne habe ich
so also zeig mal her das ist alles crap das braucht kein mensch was die haben oder braucht
vielleicht jemand weil er denkt dass er es braucht aber da sollte ich lieber was anderes
kaufen als diesen kram hier also blink ring und so kommt kommt mir nicht in die tüte die
sind hartnäckig die sind die sind hartnäckig die großen typen die wollen dass ich nochmal
zwei stück kaufe glaube ich wollte ich eine wetterfeste box suchen doch wollte ich tatsächlich
haste recht und irgendwie so eine ip 68 sowas suchen in der richtung so was hier so aber
viel zu alt da sind die noch ganz ok damit ist viel zu groß nee trocken trocken und wasserdicht
ist nicht so ist nicht so dass sowas sowas hier in der richtung reicht mir ja aber das
muss ich nicht im stream gucken das ist jetzt eigentlich ziemlich langweilig so alles müll
braucht man nicht alles die großen typen sind wirklich unglaublich hartnäckig weide
weide wo wir es gerade von hatten china geräte und unterschiedliche hersteller ist nicht
mehr drin wir hatten nämlich wir hatten nämlich vorhin sachen guck mal die dinger sehen sich
auch extrem ähnlich ich würde nicht wundern wenn es der gleiche hersteller ist und einfach
nur das logo anders hier alles misst brauchen wir nicht welchen 3d drucke hast du ich habe
den hier i3 mega s habe ich vor einem jahr oder so ungefähr gekauft ich weiß gar nicht
wann genau ein jahr eineinhalb jahre oder so für meine sachen reicht ich war kurz kurz
davor mir damals so 1000 euro prusa i3 fragt mich nicht zu kaufen aber ich habe es noch
sein gelassen hätten die paypal akzeptiert hätte ich heute davon ein ich war ich habe
den im shop bestellt ich weiß das noch ich habe ich habe ich habe das bestellt bei denen
ich wollte bezahlen und es ging kein paypal die wollten irgendwas anderes haben und habe
ich mir gesagt hä was ist da los dann habe ich die angeschrieben habe gesagt hier jungs
ist so was ihr euch da vorstellt funktioniert nicht lasst mich mal paypal bezahlen und dann
haben die mir den link generiert zum paypal bezahlen und dann habe ich nie bezahlt und
habe mir dafür einen billigeren 3d drucker gekauft also ich habe immer noch die bestellung
offen von dem von dem teuren 3d drucker was druckst du denn alles ja nicht so viel deswegen
war es eine gute sache dass ich das nicht gemacht habe wenn man auf der zweiten seite
von halbautomatisierung ich trug hauptsächlich gehäuse für mein technikraums ich habe schon
mal ich habe auch schon mal ein paar sachen gedruckt wo man dann zum beispiel led zum
led ring vorne an 3d drucker machen kann sowas ich habe auch ein paar tools für 3d drucker
selbst geguckt aber ich trug hauptsächlich irgendwelche cases für mein technik gebastelt
deswegen hat sich überhaupt nicht gelohnt dass ich einen teuren 3d drucker gekauft
habe ich trug so wenig und dann so so unanspruchsvolle sachen dass sich das gar nicht lohnt aber
was sich gelohnt hat ist muss ich sagen ich habe ja vor einer weile mal haben wir das
könnten sogar im stream gemacht habe ich bin ich mir sicher mal wirklich ganz genau
mein mein drucker bett gelevelt das hat wirklich was gebracht die drucke sind jetzt viel besser
ist ein drucker noch stock mit sicherheit der nachfolge auf jeden fall guck mal da warum
kosten jetzt 100 euro mehr bei mir hat er 219 moment warum kosten der mehr der jetzt
zu beliebt geworden dass die dass die der china hersteller sich das kann man teurer
machen die drei mega
büsten any cubic mega es wie oder details ich habe nichts gesagt ich habe für den gleichen
preis gekauft ich habe jetzt irgendwie gedacht er war 100 euro günstiger na gut ich habe
sogar fünf euro mehr bezahlt so in dem dreh habe ich hier ok ich habe nichts gesagt guck
mal hier best das stimmt da die ding also generell sind 3d drucker bei in china deutlich
deutlich billiger also das das lohnt sich mal gucken wie sieht es mal bengut aus bengut
das das lohnt sich doch dann haben wir germany eu priority mail top 60 cent versand
die chinesen aber wenn das kommt aus auch aus aus cz ist das tschechien oder so das
nicht china aus china ist da sogar top fack ist das serious ja deswegen habe ich doch
in meinem video gesagt das ist natürlich richtig tibet wer mein wer mein letztes video gesehen
hat ich habe mal wieder video auf youtube gemacht habe ich gesagt ich verstehe gar nicht warum
so viele leute sagen ich kaufe mir das jetzt nicht ich warte auf black friday deal cyber
monday deal oder sonst was wenn sie doch in china bestellen können wo preislich das ganze
jahr über cyber monday preise sind für manche sachen und wisst ihr was ich auch überhaupt
nicht verstehe es gibt leute also es gibt es gibt zwei sorten von die kaufen den gleichen
china kram dann bei amazon fürs doppelte und sagen euch ich kaufe ja nicht in china weil
scheiß menschenrechte aber ich kaufe dann china kram bei amazon ist auch absolut big
brain und dann als zu welche die zu dumm für alles sind und auf wish.com gehen und
sich china kacke bei wish.com kaufen und irgendwie denken es ist kein china kram das sind das
sind die richtigen kack noobs alter wer bei wish bestellt der hat wirklich die kontrolle
über sein leben verloren also wish die existenzberechtigung von wish erschließt sich mir überhaupt gar
nicht wish ist wirklich für nur das wish ist der der einzige grund warum es wish gibt
ist weil es so viele noobs gibt die entweder nicht wissen dass man china bestellen kann
die sich nicht trauen in china zu bestellen oder die zu doof sind in china zu bestellen
für dies wish aber mal ganz im ernst einfach direkt in china kaufen was soll denn da passieren
also wenn man bei wish schon keine angst hat gescampt zu werden dann muss man wenn man
direkt aus china bestellt auch keine angst haben gescampt zu werden weil wahrscheinlich
scammen dich die chinesen auf aliexpress weniger als die zwischenhändler auf wish weil aliexpress
als marketplace ziemlich genau guckt was die hersteller machen ich muss euch sagen ich
habe bisher mit paypal und und diesem käufer schutzprogramm mehr probleme gehabt als mit
dem aliexpress käufer schutzprogramm ich habe bei aliexpress schon ein paar sachen bestellt
ich kann mich als eine kann ich mich gut erinnern da haben die mir haben die mir geschickt das
war eine bestellung für frag mich nicht für 120 euro das war es war nicht ohne ja und
da haben die mir eine versandbeschädigung geschickt oder hat sich nichts getan das hat
sich nichts getan das hat sich nichts getan das ding stand immer noch auf irgendwie auf
den weg zum flugzeug oder so hat sich getan und irgendwann habe ich dann bei aliexpress
eine bestellung eine bestätigung bekommen aber ihre bestellung ist eingegangen ist nie
bei mir angekommen jungs was ist denn da los habe ich bei aliexpress so einen case aufgemacht
also das gleiche was man beim paypal käufer schutz ja basti jetzt fahrt mal ab was ich
gerade erzähle es ist es ist eigentlich ist es gar nicht so schlecht in china es gibt
zwar keine rechte drauf aber aliexpress guckt recht genau was diese shops da machen so und
dann habe ich einen aliexpress case aufgemacht und habe gesagt jungs was ist denn da los
angeblich ist es angekommen ich habe es nicht bekommen eure versandbestätigung sagt auch
es ist nie losgeflogen und dann hat dann der aliexpress typ drauf geantwortet ja ok der
hersteller wurde kontaktiert hersteller hat drauf geantwortet und gesagt oh ja bitte bitte
gib uns noch ein bisschen zeit und hier hast du einen neuen tracking link und der tracking
link war original das war das war massive massive debate der typ der tracking link war
exakt der tracking link vom letzten mal der schon drei oder vier wochen lang nicht funktioniert
hat er hat gemeint dass sie ja hat es jetzt neu er hat es jetzt losgeschickt das hier
wäre jetzt der richtige tracking link das war exakt der gleiche tracking link ich drauf
geantwortet das ist da immer noch der gleiche tracking link so und jetzt kommt der unterschied
zu paypal die erfahrung wie ich den paypal gemacht habe bei aliexpress war es jetzt so
die haben zu mir gesagt wenn wenn ich nicht sage der fall ist zu meiner zufriedenheit
geklärt dann also da kriege ich unter dem schritt das geld zurück also dann wird der
case nicht geschlossen sondern ich habe dann im endeffekt meine Kohle wieder gekriegt dadurch
dass ich nicht reagiert habe also bei aliexpress war es bisher so ich musste sagen es wurde
zu meiner zufriedenheit erledigt und dann wurde der case geschlossen bei paypal hatte
ich es umgedreht paypal hat dann zu mir gesagt wenn du nicht reagierst bis dahin dann schließen
wir den case und der händler kann sein kohle behalten also da war ich echt überrascht
bei aliexpress dass das quasi gut ich meine die chinesen haben die beweislastumkehr quasi
eh schon perfektioniert was das angeht dass das da aber auch so ist also ich hatte bisher
mit aliexpress käufer schutz weniger probleme als mit paypal käufer schutz bei paypal hatte
ich ich habe mir mal einen rack bestellt bei irgend so einer komischen ob sie noch gibt
ich hatte mich hier mal einen rack bestellt scheißes ding gibt es ja immer noch für online
für online shopper da hatte ich mir mal 19 zoll so ein kleines 19 zoll rack bestellt
weil es dort eben besonders günstig war ein kleines rack so was hier in der richtung
habe ich mir da bestellt das ist angekommen musstest du auch schon mal zum zoll fahren
ja ja musste ich leider muss schon öfters aber nicht aber aber noch nicht von china
nur als just aus den usa bestellt hat weil die händler aus den usa sind zu im kopf
zu verstehen wie man zolldokumente richtig macht oder umgedreht die chinesen wissen wie
man zolldokumente faked keine ahnung was da richtig ist so habe ich mir so einen schrank
bestellt hier bei dieser komischen kackplattform der kam an zerbrochene glas schreibe habe
ich hingeschrieben was jungs eure liefung ist kaputt angekommen foto gemacht hier foto
hingeschickt und keine reaktion doch doch stimmt nicht sie haben reagiert sie haben
reagiert haben irgendwie gesagt die mail ist eingegangen oder sowas und gesagt ja jungs
wie läuft es jetzt mit dem zurückschicken ist kaputt keine antwort noch mal hingeschrieben
keine antwort damit ich hingegangen habe paypal käufer schutz aufgemacht kaputt angekommen
händler reagiert nicht und dann wollte paypal dass man irgendwie noch belegt den fall ein
bisschen habe ich alles gemacht keine reaktion keine reaktion so da habe ich natürlich auch
nicht darauf reagiert und dann kam irgendwann eine meldung so nach dem motto ich müsste
jetzt reagieren sonst wird paypal das ganze zumachen der hersteller reagiert nicht und
dann hat sich paypal irgendwie eingeschaltet und am letzten tag von diesem paypal case
am letzten tag hat irgendein typ aus der stonks abteilung hier daheim angerufen von von crowdfox
und hat zu mir gesagt ey wissen sie was behalten sie das ding es ist ihnen zu teuer zurück
zu schicken ich meine sie haben ich zwar mehr oder weniger gefragt so wollen sie es behalten
oder zurückschicken sie können es ruhig behalten sagt er gut wenn ihr mich so fragt
behalte ich habe ich halt die glastüre ausgemacht aber auch okay habe ich dann umsonst gekriegt
weil es war dann in ordnung aber das letzten tag und hätte ich nicht reagiert hätte paypal
gesagt ane gibt keine kohle und bei aliexpress war es genau umgedreht also man mag zwar keine
rechte auf dem papier haben bei aliexpress wo man rechtlich dagegen vorgehen kann was
machst du mit dem ding ohne glastür ehrlich gesagt habe ich mittlerweile weggeschmissen
excellent username sehe ich schon dankeschön für den sub also man mag man mag bei aliexpress
auf dem papier keine rechte haben aber die sind da recht genau was ihre händler auf
ihrem platz auf ihrer plattform machen weil man muss ja sagen aliexpress ist ja nur den
marketplace also sprich wenn ich hier bei wenn ich hier irgendwas auf macht bei aliexpress
das kommt nie selbst von aliexpress das kommt immer von von shop also vertrauenswürdigerer
name kann ein shop ja gar nicht haben shop 5 5 9 4 0 4 6 würde ich immer wieder kaufen
oder hier ist es bei gogo store store also ich habe bisher nur gute was ich sagen will
ich habe bisher nur gute erfahrung gemacht was china bestellungen angeht und dort wo
ich keine guten erfahrungen gemacht habe halt mit weil es nicht ankam oder sowas aber
auch wirklich wenig war ganz kleiner teil hat mit der jeweilige händler plattform geholfen
also ich kann da nichts negatives sagen warum ist das deiner meinung nach ein big brain
username ja ist es nicht ist es ist es ist es ein low brain username muss du mir erklären
das ist ja dein username vielleicht ist es vielleicht ist es auch nicht big brain vielleicht
ist es auch low brain kann ja auch sein mach auch den username go buy fast so so dinger
gibt es die store name sind teilweise echt total bescheuert bei aliexpress
ja das hatte ich auch schon bei webcams webcams oder mikros zu hause rumliegen ja die sind
ja auch teilweise nicht blöd bei den shops also die sagen dann schon oftmals so ein scheiß
drauf behalts genau wich ist nichts anderes als dropship drop shipping die geben im endeffekt
den chinesen deine adresse und die chinesen schicken zu dir der wish händler hat damit
überhaupt nichts zu tun oh ja also so keiner das kenne ich
ich habe einen adapter um mit keyboard maus auf der ps4 zu spielen das ist ja eh schon
verpönt also das ist ja das ist ja quasi schon schieten aber ich muss euch mal was
ich muss euch ja was gestehen leute ich habe auch so ein teil aber ich habe einen anderen
ich habe irgendeinen ich glaube so ein ding habe ich immer gekauft excellent so ein ding
habe ich das ist noch mehr das ist noch mehr cheat als das andere ja so aber ehrlich gesagt
hat auch nicht dazu gefühlt dass ich lieber auf konsole spiele ja und ich habe mir mal
in usa also das wo ich am meisten zoll dafür bezahlt haben war mein dreamscreen
das ist so ein ambi light ding das macht man hinter dem fernseher und dann macht es so
ein auf ambi light gibt es übrigens nicht mehr die sind pleite mittlerweile so ein teil
hatte bestellt muss man sich halt in usa bestellen so und am ende habe ich quasi fast das doppelte
bezahlt als bei den dem shop gekostet gekostet hat also da kam dann am ende kam irgendwie
die amifat noch irgendwie drauf dann kam mehrwertsteuer drauf zoll drauf und ich weiß
noch der typ beim zoll oh gott das war das das war wirklich mega mega low-prane aktion
ja die fragen die dürfen es ja nicht aufmachen beim zoll beim zoll die dürfen es behalten
und die können es dann quasi mit dir zusammen aufmachen also haben wir aufgemacht reingeguckt
und da habe ich ihr da hat er gefahren was ist es habe ich gesagt ja das ist sind im
endeffekt lichter die macht man hinten so ein fernseher dran oder hat er mal alles
für ein fernseher gerät nein das ist kein das ist kein fernseher gerät das sind lichter
die macht man an fernseher dran hat er nicht verstanden oder hat er versucht ihn so raus
zu bekommen was ist es denn jetzt also wozu gehört das jetzt gehört es jetzt zu fernseher
gerät oder gehört das zu beleuchtung oder ich glaube der hat bis zum ende nicht kapiert
dass es kein fernseher ist sondern ein led strip den man hinten am fernseher dran pappt
wie bezahlst du bei aliexpress kommt immer darauf an was der jeweilige shop anbietet
deswegen mag ich bengut eigentlich weil man war bengut relativ oft mit paypal bezahlen
kann guck mal mal ob wir hier auch mit paypal bezahlen können ja kann man was ist denn klar
das ist bestimmt was russisches ja bei aliexpress hängt es halt auch extrem vom shop ab was
man damit bezahlen kann also das schlimmste bei aliexpress da muss ich mal bei alipay
bezahlen alipay zu einer zeit wo alipay noch komplett auf chinesisch war da habe ich mir
ein account gemacht mit google translator bei alipay ich weiß gar nicht mehr wie man
da was aufladen konnte mit alipay konnte man dann alipay paypal überweisen also ich
weiß es gar nicht mehr ehrlich gesagt ich krieg das gar nicht mehr zusammen zumindest
muss ich zumindest muss ich den account bei alipay machen um das bezahlen zu können das
war echt abenteuerlich alipay account mit google translator und dort ein account angelegt
also ich bezahle am liebsten bei paypal wenn es bei dem jeweiligen shop möglich ist ich
bin damit gar nicht sicher weil ich bin aber bengut weiß ich da habe ich das letzte das
mit paypal bestellt dass das geht bei aliexpress ich bezahle immer am liebsten per paypal wenn
es möglich ist übrigens es gibt jetzt ich habe heute werbung bekommen von paypal das
es jetzt eine paypal karte gibt karte oder so wie ist das ich habe es doch hier liegen
paypal debit card nicht die digit die mit card also eine kreditkarte im endeffekt und
ich bin ernsthaft überlegen normalerweise wenn ich werbung bekomme mache ich das nie
das ist aber so ein ding da muss ich sagen ich bin wirklich geneigt das zu machen weil
ich habe schon oft überlegt wie wäre das nicht gut wenn man mit aliexpress nicht aliexpress
vergessen wenn man nicht mit paypal einfach bezahlen könnte oder wenn man sein paypal
gut haben einfach ganz normal verwenden könnte und das ging nie das ging die ganze zeit nicht
du musstest das immer auf dein normales bankkonto überweisen und damit geht das und ich bin
wirklich am überlegen das jetzt zu machen ich habe immer so viel kohle bei paypal rum
gammeln dass das dass ich mich schon oft gewünscht habe dass ich den scheiß jetzt mal bei paypal
bezahlen gibt es monatliche kosten für ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung ich habe keine ahnung
fies das ist nicht kostet sich dafür anzumelden ist ja wohl mal selbstverständlich oder mein
hallo kostet nix irgendwelche service fees überziehungsgebühren oder sowas ausladen
überweisen ich muss mir das mal genauer angucken aber das war seit langem eine werbung die
ich gesehen habe wo ich mir nach ok kann ich mal so schlecht könnte man vielleicht machen
ja ich habe aktuell auch von der sparkasse noch eine kredit oder mastercard da bezahle
ich auch irgendwie paar euro im jahr für aber eigentlich brauche ich die mittlerweile
gar nicht mehr weil paypal sich jetzt schon auch bei china shops und allem durchgesetzt
hat eigentlich brauche ich gar keine wenn ich so richtig überlege es gibt eigentlich
so gut wie nix was ich mit kreditkarte bezahle ok ok ok doch aber sage ich euch nicht was
und es ist nicht belldelfin undy ferns aber die haben plus kreditkarten an nur kreditkarte
aber ansonsten brauche ich für nix eine kreditkarte und eines ist auch nicht pornhub premium aber
ansonsten brauche ich brauchst du echt für nix meine kreditkarte so ist überhaupt stehengeblieben
hier was was was wollte ich denn jetzt machen genau wie man bezahlt ja wie gesagt wenn es
geht immer paypal
so
Geh doch mal in dich was sind denn die gründe warum du das machen willst sag mir das mal
Wie bist du da drauf gekommen weil du das machen willst
Weil bevor bevor ich dir irgendwelche generik sachen erzähle wäre es doch sinnvoller es wäre irgendwas was auch auf dich zutrifft oder
Es sei nur du willst das gar nicht machen
Also es muss ja irgendwas gegeben haben dass jetzt gesagt hast ja das ist was was ich machen will
Geld kriegst du auch woanders ja
Also sprich es muss ja irgendwo mal
Irgendwas muss ich auf die idee gebracht haben und sei es nur mein video was ich dazu gemacht habe vielleicht irgendwann mal
Warum du das machen willst
Lucas drei zwanzig
Bitcoins nutze google apple pay
So also was man hier wieder schön sieht auch der 3d drucke kostet quasi 100 euro weniger beim in china
So aber ich wollte jetzt gerade noch mal schauen ob die irgendwelche guten
Kann man hier filtern bei aliexpress ist auch schon ein bisschen rotzeit oder also du findest ja da echt nix
schiff aus
schiff aus germany excellent
Aquare cube schon getestet nein aber ich habe einen bestellt
Schip schip aus germany kostet gleich über moment das moment
Okay, aber nicht viel billiger als
Okay, also interesse an software hardware lösen vom problem klassiker im bildschirm ist noch schwarz wenn ich die rechne anscheide oder hilfe ich
Hab das hinweg gelöscht ansonsten basic ja genau das
Genau das kannst du reinschreiben
Gerade das hier gerade das hier dass du dich für netzwerke interessierst dass du dich für für logische sachen und programmieren
Interessierst dass du dich fürs lösen von problemen interessierst auch allgemein dass du
Dass du
Interesse software hardware ist sehr sehr sehr
Generic ja aber gerade das hier lösen von problemen ist eine super geschichte dass dass du dich für programmieren interessiert dass du dich für netzwerke interessiert
Diese sachen zusammen ist eigentlich optimal für ein fachinformatiker
Ach so für hobbies
Ja gut woher soll ich wissen was du da für hobbies reinschreiben kannst
Tja das ist halt die frage was es für ein laden ist also ich würde ja
Es nicht negativ auslegen wenn einer sagt es spielt er spielt competitive counter strike oder sowas in dem team da würde ich sogar sagen
Hey, das ist cool
Den würde ich vielleicht sogar dann keine ahnung beim bewerbungsgespräch fragen sag mal was bist du für rank
Aber es mag bestimmt den ein oder anderen
boomer human resources
human resources typ geben
Der damit nichts anfangen kann
Sich interessieren und können sind leider noch zwei verschiedene paar schuhe
Ja, aber es doch egal
Deswegen machst du deine ausbildung du machst ja keine ausbildung dass du das schon weil du schon alles
Kannst also es gibt meiner meinung noch viel zu viele azubis die der meinung sind sie können das alles schon und sie machen die ausbildung
nur weil
Sie brauchen einen zettel wo das drauf steht das stimmt bei den meisten nicht die damit anfangen
So wenn es genau dass die bewerbung für ausbilder wenn er sich halt zu viel bewirbt dann
Muss er ja nichts können ok wenn du gelben rauslassen willst ehrlich gesagt ja
Was weiß ich was man da reinschreiben kann ich habe schon ewig keine bewerbung mehr geschrieben und ich mit mittlerweile aber hobby tatsächlich
Reinschreiben dass ich sachen aber ok
Ja was könnten bei so einer stonks firma gut ankommen als hobbies
Schreibt wandern und radfahren rein das ist so schön unverfänglich da kann keiner was gegen sagen
Golfspiel
Aber
Wenn du da nichts willst du da es ich mein
Wenn du da was reinschreiben willst als hobby was was technisches ist
Also was was irgendwie zu dem zu dem
Beruf passt
Was könnte man da schreiben
Die idee finde ich gut doch der chat der chat ist heute mal wieder enorm hilfreich also ernst gemeint das finde ich gut
Technologien ausprobieren
Wenn ich es ist ist ein super hobby wenn man sich wenn man sich als fahrinformatiker entdeckt also das fände ich cool wenn das drinnen steht
Schach alter spielst du wirklich schach oder hast du einfach nur schach reingeschrieben weil es sich big brain anhören soll
Das ist fair das ist kack Stunden
Also
für. Sie sollte man nicht erwarten dass er das kann
wenn man
natürlich sagt
Ich interessiere mich für programmieren ich habe schon ein paar kleine k fist
Kann man sich so ein fewHis
Das ist ultraktfo
Na wenn jemand natürlich sagt hey
Ich interessiere mich für programmieren ich habe schon ein paar kleine sachen gemacht ist es das eine aber da kann man ja nicht jetzt hier von von
Großartigen Kenntnissen und großartig können sprechen das ist eher so ich interessiere mich ein bisschen für
Aber ich finde man sollte als du bist nicht so sehr danach auswählen
Ob sie ob sie irgendwie sachen quasi jetzt gleich schon voll einsatzfähig machen können
Dafür sind ausbildung da dass das aus meiner sicht ist das wichtigste was ein azubi haben muss der muss ich eben für die
Inhalte interessieren weil sobald dass ich für die inhalt interessiert kommt der rest mehr oder weniger von allein
Bildest du aus ich da ich habe keinen also ich habe weder eine eigene firma mit azubis noch habe ich irgendwie die offizielle
Lizenz zum ausbilden oder sowas aber ich habe bei uns hat ab und zu schon paar azubis betreut und bin da auch öfters mal bei
Irgendwelchen abschluss präsentationen und monatsdingern und ausbildungsberichte geduldens und krams dabei
Ja das heißt ich bin ja nicht ganz komplett planlos
Das ist eine ausrede für wir verstehen uns nicht würde ich sagen das ist blablabla
In der regel nicht aber ich war schon bei ich war schon bei welchen dabei und
Also was mich immer nervt sind personalleute
Am besten ist bei uns unsere personalleute in letzter ich war aber schon eine ganze weine nicht
Mal dabei am besten sind unsere personalleute die dann
stellenanzeigen schreiben es geht es nicht so sehr um azubis auch im andern die stellenanzeigen schreiben auf grundlage dessen was in irgendeinem typ
Erzählt hat was man technisch braucht da kommt dann stellenanzeigen raus wo ich mir so denke alter da hat sich wirklich jemand drauf beworben
Das sind dann so stellenanzeigen wie wir suchen leute mit erfahrung in
cisco
mw windows linux sun firewalls kernel entwicklung java entwicklung
devops cloud azure aws google cloud plattform
Wer hat das denn geschrieben und dass sich da auch wirklich leute drauf bewärben
Also ja das ist ja so alles es ist teilweise ganz wir
Wir hatten mal für unseren sup jetzt kein witz für unseren support für unseren support
Hatten wir mal eine stellenanzeige
da stand drin
eitel
das geht schon gut los
eitel zertifizierung
erfahrungen
zabbix
redhead
vmware
also windows ad
hochverfügbare systeme cloud
Es war noch drin das war es gewesen da ich glaube es war noch mehr drin
Es ging irgendwie so in die richtung weiter für den support
also für
ich gehe ans telefon und nehmen und nehmen
eine störung auf und leite eine entstörung in die wege bei den eigentlichen leuten die sich damit ausgehen für den support
Also da waren sie echt also das war wirklich komplett jenseits ist voll das realistischen ja
Ja da haben sich leute drauf bevor ach ja ach ja ich habe die wichtigste
Bereitschaft zur schichtarbeit des wichtigste habe ich ja vergessen bereitschaft zur schicht ab zur schicht wochenend und nachtarbeit
War noch dabei also nur vom feinsten nur vom aller feinsten
Und ihr werdet es nicht glauben da haben sich leute darauf beworben aber das witzige war die haben es richtig gemacht
Die haben es richtig gemacht die haben nämlich schon predicted
dass die stellenanzeige kacke ist
Und die haben sich darauf beworben und hatten vielleicht
zwei drei sachen davon
Und wurden dann trotzdem genommen
Weil die haben richtig predicted die haben predicted die stellenanzeige ist von deppen oder naja was heißt verdämpft von
nicht so sehr in der materie
Leute nicht so sehr in der materie drin ist geschrieben worden
Geschrieben worden und das haben die richtig predicten heute sind sie am start
Und am geilsten war ich würde sie euch ja zeigen aber dann dann sieht man wo ich arbeite das will ich auch nicht
Ich sag ja immer ich sag nur bei einer bank in frankfurt da gibt es jetzt ja doch schon genug ja also da
Fertig sieht man das nicht so banken in frankfurt gibt es ja wo du hinspuckst
Back soll vergessen was ich sagen wollte
Genau
Da stand in der stellenanzeige stand dann auch drinne was die vorteile sind von
dieser
Arbeitgeber
Stand da drin
Und das war wie wir uns hier manchmal stellenanzeige angucken ja
Das war
Das
Unkreativst überhaupt da stand dann drinne
Überdurchschnittliche vergütung das schreiben wir alle rein gute entwicklungsmöglichkeiten ein moderner und und
Zukunfts
Fähige arbeitsplatz oder irgendwie sowas stand da drinne also das stand nichts drinne wirklich gar nichts wo ich sagen will
Oh ja da will ich hin
Und ich habe dann irgendwann mal mit die mühe gemacht und habe dem chef
Von dieser abteilung der wo dieser support arbeitet habe ich ihm mal ein paar sachen dazu geschrieben was mich persönlich
Jetzt von den vorteilen die wir haben in der firma dazu bringen würde
Das in der wegung zu ziehen ja zum beispiel dass wir flexibel flexibel aber als eine form von
Zeitsystem dass wir
höhenverstellbare schreibtische haben dass wir eine eigene kantine haben dass wir
Ich weiß gar nicht was ich mal so dinge und ich habe das sind wirklich plus punkte
Wo man sagen könnte ja das gefällt mir man gerade eine kantine im haus ist super oder ja im haus nicht aber
Das subventionierte kantine in der nähe
Und
Auch auch gerade für leute die
Da ganz die die die da wirklich 24 sieben support machen für die ist ein höhenverstellbarer schreibtisch und sonstige technischen sachen sicherlich auch ganz interessant ja
Dann dass man ein kostenloses ipad iphone bekommt zum beispiel und auch privat verwenden kann das sind so sachen
Wo ich mir denke das sind vorteile schreibt die doch rein und nicht so dieses 0815 generic zeug ein toller zukunftsfähiger
arbeitsplatz bei einem der besten der branche oder so gedöns wer wer lässt sich von so einem
ipad nicht jeder aber iphone jeder
ipad kriegt nicht jeder aber es gibt ein paar die haben ipad aber ein iphone kriegt jeder
Aber es gibt auch
gerade wenn du im support arbeitest sind die chancen dass du relativ hoch dass du ein ipad kriegst weil das support muss
unsere mobile apps testen
täglich und deswegen hat
man da ein ipad für
normales kein pro ganz normales
Ja so das habe ich mit dem passant über sehen
wurde bei uns auch letztens gelochen
Ja das ist überhaupt nicht erlaubt, dass das pop das das probieren bei uns auch bei uns wird auch
ein bisschen was halt kannst du nicht reden das geht doch gar nicht
Der witz ist halt
Du hast eigentlich keine vorteile dadurch nicht über das gehalt zu sprechen
Der einzige vorteil ist dass du nicht über das gehalt sprichst
Der einzige vorteil ist ein arbeitgeber weil
Wenn die leute nicht untereinander nicht wissen was der andere verdient da kann er natürlich sagen
Ah ja ne ne also da ist jetzt leider leider gar nichts mehr drinne wenn ich mir das so ankomme wenn du natürlich weißt dass irgendwelche anderen leute
Sehen wir ein drittel mehr bekommen die ähnliche sachen machen wie du tja ist alles schwierig
Wie sich dann erklären soll warum das bei denen okay ist
So portig ich bin mir gar nicht sicher ob das bei mir nicht auch drinne steht
Ich könnte mir ich glaube sogar da steht drinne oder stand drinne in der alten variante
Aber da ist e fraglich wie gesell also wie haltbar so dinger sind
Aber ich rede ja auch gar nicht übers gehalt war ich nie
Ich rede über wenn schon über stufen im tarifvertrag und
Beschäftigten jahre und sonst was und da kommt man auch schon ziemlich gut hin was am ende rauskommt
Klar jeder hat noch ein bisschen bonus obendrauf also es ist bei uns nicht der nackte tarifvertrag mit
Jahren und stufe
Es hat hier noch ein bisschen bonus obendrauf was ein bisschen so wenig ist es jetzt eigentlich gar nicht
Aber man kommt ja auch noch ein bisschen
So wenig ist es jetzt eigentlich gar nicht aber man kommt schon recht gut ein gefühl für was man so verdient
Ohne dass man wirklich was galt reden muss
Und außerdem bei uns
Und außerdem ist es bei uns so dass die auch öfters mal
Dass die abrechnung nicht so ganz stimmt und allein schon aus dem kund tauschen tauschen sich die leute aus
Das heißt dieses fast will da gar keine aufmachen dass jemand wirklich da drauf besteht und sagt ihr dürft da nicht drüber reden
Ja gibt es
Weil die leute müssen miteinander reden dann halt schon um zu überprüfen ob ihre abrechnung stimmt man darf sie nicht vergessen
Dass es eigentlich ein unding ist dass sie das seit
drei jahren oder so nicht hinbekommen dass die abrechnung also seit über drei jahren ist bei manchen leuten kontinuierlich die abrechnung
Also kontinuierlich immer wieder bei den gleichen leuten die abrechnung falsch hallo wir sind einer der größten
Finanzdinger in deutschland
Kann doch nicht sein da fack. Na ja
Ja
Das kann ich das kann ich zum teil verstehen
Die frage ist halt nur wenn die was ähnliches machen wie du warum sie nur so einen hungerloben bezahlen
Ich
Was wurde meist tener ob ich bereit wäre vor ausbildungscanzlern treibern praktikum
zu machen, um nötige Voraussetzungen...
Das finde ich nicht verkehrt.
Das finde ich sinnvoll, sowas zu machen, ja.
Ja, Whitebird, das ist ein Rinder,
richtig bescheuert. Das finde ich
gut, sowas. Übrigens, das zeugt
meiner Meinung nach auch davon, dass das
eine ganz gute Firma ist, wenn die sagen,
hey, an sich würden wir gut
zusammenpassen, aber wir schlagen
vor zur Vorbereitung, das zu machen.
Das finde ich nicht schlecht.
Das sind eh die Besten.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob ich euch schon mal
erzählt hab, wie damals mein
Bewerbungsgespräch gelaufen ist,
wo ich mich für die Ausbildung beworben habe.
Also ich hab ja mal vor
etwas längerer Zeit...
war das dann.
Ich hab mal
eine Ausbildung gemacht,
Fachinformatik und Systemintegration.
Das war übrigens nicht
meine erste Ausbildung.
Ich hab davor
Stonkszeug gemacht.
Aber da hatte ich keinen Bock mehr drauf.
Und ich habe
schon immer Stonkszeug gehasst.
Ich hab...Wirtschaft BWL
kann es mich echt jagen mit. Ich weiß gar nicht,
was mich da gerissen hat, ja.
Naja.
So, zumindest habe ich da noch
eine Fachinformatik-Ausbildung gemacht, was im Endeffekt
auch das war, was ich machen wollte.
Und ich hab mich damals
bei einem Provider beworben.
Und...
Ich hab mir ja sonst was ausgemalt,
wie das funktioniert.
Also mit Bewerbungen
und Vorstellungsgespräch und sonst was.
Und ich hab gedacht, da kommen jetzt die ultrakomplizierten
fiesen Fragen und so.
Ich glaube, ich habe im Nachhinein
eine Sache richtig gemacht, die ist mir aber
im Nachhinein eingeleuchtet.
Also ich bin da hingefahren
zu dem Provider.
Ich wurde eingeladen.
Ich bin hingefahren.
Und...
Dann gab es erstmal so eine...
Basic-Test.
Und die haben damals auch gesagt,
das ist eigentlich nicht der Test für Azubis.
Sondern das ist der Test, den auch normale
Leute bei ihnen kriegen. Sie wollen einfach
nur mal gucken, wie man sich schlägt.
Ich glaube, das war ein bisschen
Zeit im Nachhinein.
Ich glaube, die wollten mal gucken, wie die Leute darauf reagieren,
wenn man ihnen was hinschmeißt, wovon sie gar keinen Plan haben.
Eigentlich gar keine so blöde Idee.
Da waren Fragen drin, ey.
Da wusste ich damals echt nicht genau. Aber...
Ich kannte mich damals ein bisschen
Linux-mäßig schon aus. Und ich hatte
auch ein bisschen schon mit Cisco-Switchen rumgespielt.
Das heißt, ich konnte denen zumindest
ein paar Cisco-Befehle sagen in diesem
Test. Und ich konnte denen auch
ein paar IP-Tables-Sachen sagen.
Und, das weiß ich heute noch,
und ich konnte ihnen sagen, wie man aus Wim
rauskommt.
Die wollten wirklich wissen, wie man
aus Wim rauskommt.
Und da gab es noch ein paar andere dofe Tests.
So was weiß ich. Das Zahlen, die man sich merken soll.
Und ach, blaaa.
Zumindest war
der Test vorbei. Zumindest
war der Test vorbei. Und danach
musste man halt nochmal
zum Chef. Oder zu den zwei
Chefs.
Und die haben einen halt nochmal
interviewt. So. Und das war dann
eigentlich so das eigentliche Vorstellungsgespräch.
So, und da habe ich unbewusst
glaube ich
was richtig gemacht.
Also es war keine Taktik oder so.
Das habe ich aus der Not heraus gemacht, weil
ich nicht wusste, was ich sagen soll.
Und zwar, ich bin ins Büro rein.
Da habe ich mich hingesetzt. Und das
erste, was ich gesagt habe, war
der Test war schon ganz schön gemein.
Und wir hatten
instant ein Gesprächsthema, was
in die Richtung ging, wie ich wollte.
Weil das nächste, was die mich gefragt
haben ist, ja warum?
Und dann konnte ich übelst Technikgrabens
labern, dass die gemerkt haben,
dass ich
von manchen Sachen mich schon ganz gut auskenne.
Und habe gesagt, ja
ich wusste genau, bei IP Tables
haben wir die und die Tabellen, aber
ich wusste nicht mal genau,
ob man Mängeln jetzt dabei
muss oder nicht. Also sprich,
im Prinzip habe ich mich darüber ausgelassen,
warum ich manche Sachen in dem Test verkackt
habe. Und da
wollten sie dann auch irgendwelche Dinge wissen, so nach dem
Motto,
was war denn das?
Ob ich wüsste, ob ich wüsste, was die Firma
macht und solche Geschichten,
ne, ne, ne, nicht ob ich wüsste, was die Firma
macht, sondern sie haben mir ein paar Sachen gesagt,
die die Firma macht, ob ich mir darunter was vorstellen
kann.
Zum Beispiel Monitoring,
das weiß ich schon, die haben mich gefragt,
die haben mich gefragt,
ob ich mir unter Monitoring was vorstellen könnte.
Da habe ich gesagt, ja so was
wie Herzrate.
So was wie Herzrate,
Alter.
Nein, nein,
nicht im Krankenhaus,
hat er gesagt, nicht im Krankenhaus.
Nicht im Krankenhaus.
So, und
ganz ehrlich, wir haben da eigentlich
10 Minuten ganz normal gelabert,
oder 15 Minuten, ich weiß gar nicht mehr genau.
Und ganz ehrlich, ich bin da rausgegangen
und habe mir gedacht, okay,
was ist das?
Ich bin da rausgegangen und habe mir gedacht,
okay, war doch eigentlich gar nicht so schlimm.
Und einen Tag später,
einen Tag später morgens,
um halb acht,
das waren Zeiten, da habe ich bis elf gepennt oder so,
haben die mich angerufen
und haben gemeint, ja, ob ich
vorbeikommen will, Vertrag unterschreiben.
Ich war doch gestern erst da.
Sie haben sich schon entschieden.
Okay, ich komme vorbei. Auf geht's.
Also, das war wirklich easy
im Nachhinein.
Und ich glaube, das war wirklich,
das lief auch nur so gut,
weil ich irgendwas Blödes am Anfang gesagt habe,
wie der Tester war, aber fies,
weil dann ging es gleich in die richtige
Richtung, wo ich dann halt auch was sagen
konnte zu.
Ach ja, und,
ich weiß auch noch,
da war noch so ein anderer
Typ dabei.
Ich überlege gerade, es waren drei Leute dabei
und ich glaube, einer hat danach auch noch mit mir angefangen.
Zumindest, da war so ein Typ dabei,
der ultra korrekt,
so übelst raus
geputzt, mit Anzug,
Lederschuhen,
gescheitelt,
gehahngegegelt, ey,
Alter, wie aus dem Ei gepellt,
als bewirbt er sich jetzt irgendwie für den Vorsitzenden
der Europäischen Zentralbank oder sowas.
Keine Ahnung, übelst raus, kurz.
Und der Kerl, der war, wahrscheinlich wollte er
den Anzug gar nicht anziehen, wahrscheinlich haben seine Eltern gesagt
oder so, Alter, zieh den Anzug an, kommt
gut an. Der saß da,
der hat gezittert, der war
fettig mit den Nerven. Ich muss sagen, ich war auch
übelst aufgeregt, ja.
Aber mir ist das merkwürdig.
Bei mir ist das merkwürdig, es ist ganz komisch.
Wenn ich,
also, ich hab so zwei,
ja, ja, Bewerb,
ich hab so zwei Stufen.
Ich hab so zwei Stufen.
Wenn ich, also, ich hab so
eine Stufe, ich bin aufgeregt
und ich hab die Stufe,
ich hab Panik bei irgendwas, ja.
Also, was weiß ich, wenn mich jetzt ein Hund
anspringt, dann hab ich Panik und hab natürlich Schiss
und krieg irgendein Adrenalin,
krieg übelst Panik und so vieles, ja.
Okay, das kennt, glaub ich, jeder.
Aber,
ähm,
wenn ich einfach nur
aufgeregt bin,
dann ist es bei mir meistens so,
dass ich gar nicht unbedingt,
ich werd' ein bisschen hüppeliger, na, was im Prinzip
jeder hat. Du bist, du bist ein bisschen
aufgeregter, aber was ich hab, ist, wenn ich
aufgeregt bin,
ich hab das,
ich fang übelst, ähm,
an, über alles nachzudenken.
Also, bei mir ist es so,
bei mir geht das Aufgeregtsein weniger
in, in schwitzen und hüppelig werden
über, sondern zu,
ähm,
irgendwie übelst aufmerksam sich alles angucken
über alles nachdenken und sonst wie. Also,
ich, ich kann das, kann das, kann das,
kann das schlecht betreiben,
beschreiben, ja. Ich werd' dann, ich werd' dann,
äh, für einen kurzen Moment Fivehead.
Das geht, das hält nicht lang, das hält nicht, das hält nicht
lang, ja. Ähm,
so. Zumindest,
also ich,
was ich damit sagen will, ich war da natürlich auch
aufgeregt, aber halt, so auf meine Art und Weise
aufgeregt. So.
Aber der andere Typ, der war halt
aufgeregt in Form von
halb angefangen zu schwitzen und zu
zittern und seh', ja.
Der, der war übelst fertig.
Ähm, übrigens bei mir führt das dann auch
dazu, ich bin, wenn ich irgendwas, was
präsentieren muss oder so, da bin ich auch
aufgeregt vorher, aber irgendwie
ist das dann auch so ein Aufgeregtsein,
dass ich mich sogar drauf freue.
Weil, man hat sich da drauf vorbereitet,
das Beste, was man übrigens machen kann, das ist bei so
Lifehack, ja.
Wenn ihr irgendwas machen müsst,
wie, wie was präsentieren, ich hab das früher
absolut ungern gemacht, ich hab's gehasst.
Ich habe, ich habe präsentieren vorstellen
müssen wir sagen, absolut gehasst.
Und, ähm,
bis ich dann irgendwann mal gemerkt hab,
dass
dadurch, dass man
es absolut ungern
macht, man sich auch noch
ungern damit
beschäftigt.
Und dadurch, dass man es nicht gern
macht, sich damit auch nicht beschäftigt,
sind die Ergebnisse auch immer total
beschissen. Weil, ich mein, was soll dabei
rauskommen? Stell euch vor, man ist jemand,
der nicht gerne sich vorne alleine hinstellt
und was präsentiert.
Und, man ist dann auch nicht
drauf vorbereitet. Was soll da am Ende
rauskommen? Es wird einfach kacke.
Das Ergebnis wird einfach peinlich und scheiße.
Sehr logisch irgendwo, ja?
Man hat eh schon nicht so wirklich gutes Talent
für und kein Bock drauf und man hat sich nicht
vorbereitet und es ist scheiße am Ende was rauskommen.
So, aber was ich
gemerkt hab, ist, wenn man
sich zumindest bei solchen Sachen
mit dem
Thema beschäftigt, das ist
das ist die halbe Miete.
Man muss das Thema
nicht mögen, man muss es auch
nicht geil finden, sich vorne hinzustellen,
aber wenn man sich mit dem Thema, was man
vorstellen muss,
beschäftigt hat, da hat man schon gefühlt mehr gemacht
als die meisten anderen, die irgendwas
präsentieren und wenn man dann
aufgeregt ist, dann führt das
zumindest bei mir dazu,
dass ich nicht etwa
anfange die Sachen zu vergessen oder so,
sondern, dass mir alles,
was ich mir in der Vorbereitung angeguckt
habe und was ich im Vorfeld auch schon mal
geübt habe, dass mir das dann
quasi alles auf einmal wieder
einfällt. Klingt letztendlich
toll, wenn ihr eine Präsentation schon ein paar
mal geübt habt, also wenn ihr die, ihr müsst euch
nicht von Spiegel stellen, ich bin jetzt auch
niemand, der Ultrapräsentation-Guidelines
irgendwie How-to-Rhetorik geben kann oder so,
bin ich wirklich der Letzte,
der das wirklich gut kann, ja,
aber ich kann es mittlerweile ganz okay, würde ich sagen
und, ähm,
wo auch ein bisschen Videos machen auf YouTube geholfen haben,
würde ich sagen, ähm,
wenn ihr euch da vorbereitet habt und das
ein paar Mal vor euch hin gesprochen habt
oder am besten auch mit ein paar Leuten, die
ihr gern habt, die ihr mögt,
das mal gezeigt habt
und wenn ihr
das dann anfangen eure Präsentation
und dann seid ihr natürlich ein bisschen nervös,
aber dadurch,
dass ihr euch vorbereitet
habt, hilft das euch quasi
besser zu denken während
der Präsentation, ihr seid dann nicht nervös,
im Panikmodus nervös, weil ihr wisst,
ähm, ihr habt euch eigentlich ganz
gut vorbereitet, sondern ihr seid dann einfach nur ein bisschen
angespannt und euch
hilft dann quasi mehr oder weniger
spontan immer, zumindest bei mir,
zu dieser Situation
das Richtige ein, was ihr in der
Vorbereitung geübt habt.
Klappt wunderbar.
So, und zumindest, warum,
lange Rede, kurzer Sinn,
ich war ja beim Vorstellungsgespräch
und ein Typ, der war halt
mega, ähm,
war halt total aufgeregt,
der hat halt wie gesagt gezittert und so scheiße, ich musste jetzt
rein und
es ist eine Sache, das ist mir heute noch
unangenehm, wenn ich darüber nachdenke,
ich glaube, ich habe den übelst
geschockten Typ.
Ich wollte das überhaupt nicht,
muss ich dazu sagen, ich glaube,
ich habe den übelst geschockt und zwar
wir haben da gehockt zu dritt,
der eine Typ schon übelst, übelst am
zittern so, fuck, fuck, fuck, gleich Vorstellungsgespräch,
Vorstellungsgespräch, da
kommen die zwei halt raus und man so, okay,
ähm, wer, wer möchte
anfangen, wer möchte anfangen
und da haben wir uns alle so angeguckt und der Typ
so hat irgendwie kein Wort rausgekriegt,
da habe ich halt gemeint, okay,
fange ich an
und dementsprechend, ne, erstes Gespräch,
10 Minuten, 10, 15 Minuten, war ich auch als erstes fertig,
logischerweise, es gibt ja nur zwei Chefs und wenn die dich
interviewen, können sich die anderen nicht interviewen
und da bin ich
rausgegangen, bin ich noch mal zu den anderen
zwei hin und hab gesagt, tschüss, macht's gut
und da hat er eigentlich, und wie war's?
und da hab ich dann zu ihm gemeint, so
Alter, was die alles wissen
wollten hier, boah
ey, der, der ist fast, der ist fast kollabiert
ey
das war überhaupt nicht meine
Absicht, ey, das ist überhaupt
nicht meine Absicht gewesen, der Typ, der war vorher
schon mega im Arsch
und ich, ey
ich glaub, der ist, der ist auseinandergeschmolzen
ey
und das wollte ich überhaupt nicht
ich
das war so eher so ne spontane Sache, so
das war ehrlich gesagt zu helflich, also
boah, bin ich froh, dass ich's hinter mir hab, so nach dem
Motto, das war wirklich keine
Absicht, deswegen ist mir das heute auch noch unangenehm, wenn ich
daran denke, ich
ich wollte den
ich sabotiere den in irgendeiner Art und Weise
ja
ah
tja
den hab ich danach auch nicht mehr gesehen
also
der oder die andere, die
da noch, ich kann mich an den dritten oder die dritte
die da dabei war, gar nicht mehr erinnern, wer das
war, aber der hat glaub ich danach auch
die Ausbildung dort angefangen, oder die
die
ich weiß es nicht mehr
der hat, wahrscheinlich hat der gedacht
ich hab's absichtlich gemacht, ja
aber hab ich nicht, hab ich echt nicht
wirklich nicht
das hab ich da überhaupt nicht dran gedacht in dem Moment
ich kann so was gar nicht
predicted machen, da bin ich viel zu low
brain für
der Friseur kann so was
wenn der drauf anlegt, kann der die Leute
auch unter den Tisch labern
der Friseur
by the way, wo sind wir eigentlich stehen geblieben?
ich hab ehrlich keine Ahnung,
wenn wir da drauf gekommen sind, Bewerbung
sonst wie
ja
Matt 9908
ich mach, ich machs ein bisschen anders
also im Prinzip ähnlich, aber ich
machs, ich machs so
wo ist es?
er schreibt hier, ich mach meine
Präsentation immer ohne Notiz, geh vor, nur ein paar
mal die Logik schreiben, ich machs ähnlich
wenn ich die
ich schreib mir am Anfang immer total viel auf
also so
unterschiedliche, so Sachen wie zum Beispiel ey
bei diesem Punkt kannst du dann das sagen, oder
vielleicht kannst du bei diesem Punkt so einen kleinen
Gag machen oder sowas, sowas schreib ich mir immer auf
wenn ich gute Ideen zu den einzelnen Punkten hab
und dann probier ich, wenn ich
die Sache 2, 3 mal
testweise halte, versuche
ich diese Sachen einzubauen
und am Ende hab ich auch keine Zettel dabei
ich hab nie Notizen dabei
ich bin viel zu konzentriert auf das
jeweilige Thema, ich lese die Notizen
eh nicht
absolut no chance, also
und ich hab am Ende trotzdem alles erzählt
was ich erzählen wollte
naja
so, ich hoffe ich hab jetzt nichts
übersehen
wir sind nicht
wirklich weit gekommen mit
Einkaufen heute, oder? Kann das sein?
der Titel ist
der Titel des Streams, ich muss das mal kurz betonen
der Titel des Streams ist
kurz Amazon checken
Cyber Monday
ich habe kurz gecheckt
gibt ja auch nichts
das stimmt
also ich hab jetzt 3 Stunden 40
gebraucht
und hab
nicht so viel gemacht ehrlich gesagt
mir kommt deine Stimme unfassbar bekannt vor
aber ich kann es nicht ein, wo erkennt man nicht
guck dir mal meinen Avatar auf Twitch an
vielleicht fällt es dir dann ein
wenn nicht
dann kennst du mich wahrscheinlich nicht von woanders
oder du hast den Avatar
nicht gemerkt, das kann natürlich auch sein
was ist denn überhaupt WLAN2GO
kenn ich nicht
sagt mir nichts
ich muss noch kurz
äh
excellent
also was wollten wir?
ich wollte gucken
ob es
gescheite Deals gibt
da ist mir aufgefallen, dass Aliexpress
total crap ist und man noch nicht mal sortieren kann
nach
ob das jetzt ein Cyber Monday Deal ist
oder nicht
kann man denn bei Banggood
wenigstens sortieren, ob das ein Cyber Monday
Deal ist oder nicht
Schwachsinn alter
oder sind das ja am Anfang alles Cyber Monday
Deals
guck grad mal ob ich irgendwas übersehen habe
im Chat kurz
übrigens, ich muss gerade nochmal
einschauen, ich hab bestimmt irgendwelche Subs übersehen
und bin ich irgendwie sehr vertieft ins
Geschwätze
Dankeschön übrigens auch für die ganzen
Follows, die es noch gegeben
hat
mach ich mal schnell durchlaufen
ich lese da normalerweise nie die Follows vor, aber
warum nicht, können wir mal
machen, dann haben wir hier am Start
Perimoth, Sandcrab
Lens Gd
bitte?
ausgesprochen
Tedem Vanus
PS485
Nikrotin, Lukas360
äh 320, nicht 360, fast
der Kaiserschnitt
der Multikiller
Skydive
Hi, alle
miteinander uns
Seekyors
Herbsen Xiton
Xiton
und Dr. Kerem
Bayrakta
alles klar
äh weiß die letzte Stunde nur, schön dass ihr alle am Start seid
und der Master Hawk eben auch noch
exzellent
Haken bei Sale, wo ist Sale? Wo ist der Sale Haken?
Wo ist hier Sale?
Ich seh es nicht, bei AliExpress meinste?
Wo ist hier denn Haken bei Sale?
Doch von YouTube, genau
richtig
ja, exzellent
haste erkannt
bei Banggood da steht Sale
wo?
ja, wir haben gerade geguckt
wie viel günstiger der gleiche 3D
Drucker ist, wenn man ihn in China kauft
Mitte oben
ach da
Moment, warum findet der Sale nicht, wenn ich Sale eingebe
aber sag bloß das ist ein Bild
das ist ein Bild
warum ist das ein Bild
die Chinesen wieder ey
da werden Wörter auch als Bilder
ok Sale
also was
haben wir da
warum soll ich 7 Euro für ein Modul bezahlen, was auch nicht mehr
hat als ein anderes Modul
viel zu
warum ist das so teuer
da fuck, das sind ja fast
ach Moment, ich hab Chips, hab ich noch Chips
vom Germany, nee, all Regions
warum ist das so teuer
was ist mit euch los
hä
das kostet normalerweise 3,50
warum kostet das jetzt das doppelte
weil es Cyber Monday ist oder wie
die Boards sind gut, die kann ich echt empfehlen
ah hier, hier haben wir noch
4,99
sag mal
Banggood ist Chebat oder
das ist überhaupt nicht im Sale
das kostet normalerweise auch nicht mehr
Banggood ist komplett das Chebat
die schreiben einfach Cyber Monday dran
und ist es überhaupt nicht, also von dem Angebot
irgendwie
es kostet normalerweise
immer so viel
ich hab noch nie
für den ESP32
NodeMC und noch nie
12 Euro bezahlt, der kostet ja
sogar 1 Euro Amazon DE
nur 8 Euro
macht fast jeder
so, ja
ist so, aber
das kostet jetzt ja genau das gleich
es kostet genau das gleiche
wie sonst
ja Spatzgranate
ich wollte eigentlich auch in einer Stunde weg sein
das ist auch so
und was ist das
ich dachte es ist ein ESP2866
es gibt doch
gar keinen offiziellen
D1 Mini ESP32
oder doch
ok, gibt es da irgendwas was sich lohnt
an Boards, wo man sagt
das bräuchte ich mal
TTGO Camera Module
diese ESP-Cams finde ich total uninteressant
und uninteressant
nichts interessantes dabei
an
Zäpfchen oder was
ach ne, da ist so ein Bodenfeuchtigkeitssensor
oder sowas
für ein Zäpfchen wäre vielleicht auch ein bisschen unangenehm
aber trotzdem
sieht schon ein bisschen so aus
glaub das ist ein Bodenfeuchtigkeitssensor
aber das sind die schlechten Bodenfeuchtigkeitssensoren
die anfangen zu rosten
mit der Zeit
oh der ist gut
der ist tatsächlich nice
alle die
ach guck mal, den gibt es auf dem kleinen
Modul
ok, das ist tatsächlich
was, was mich interessiert und zwar
das ist ein
was ist denn
das ist ein ESP32
mit einem SIM-Slot
da kann man zum Beispiel
GPS-Dat oder so verschicken, wenn man GPS-Empfänger noch hat
gar nicht so übel
aber, nichts was ich jetzt unbedingt bräuchte
ne, ist glaube ich nichts
ich bin ein fahrendes bei diesmal hier
ist es nicht wenig sinnvoll, dass Feuchtigkeitssensoren rosten können?
nein, das ist nicht sinnvoll, deswegen ist der
der Sensor ja auch ziemlicher Müll
es gibt
es gibt ein paar verschiedene
Typen von so
Bodenfeuchtigkeitssensoren
und es gibt welche, die machen das halt so
die haben links und rechts ein bisschen Metall
und leiten da quasi
Strom dazwischen durch
und messen dann den Widerstand
und anhand dessen sagen sie wie
feucht oder trockener Boden ist
das Problem ist dabei nur
dass es anfängt zu rosten
also nicht nur anfängt zu rosten, sondern auch
es fängt auch an die
die Teile sich
vom Plastik zu lösen und so richtig hängen geblieben
ich mein, dann hast ein Bodenfeuchtigkeitssensor
dann am Jahr kaputt ist
ich hab jetzt übrigens was
was neues
was altes wiederentdeckt
und zwar ich hab mir vor
ner ganzen Weile so einen
Fibaro Door
also nicht Sebaro
Fibaro Door Sensor gekauft
die es jetzt nicht
mehr gibt
und zumindest
die Version, die ich davon hab
an die kann man noch
das ist eigentlich ein Sensor, wo man checken kann
ob die
ne Tür oder
ein Gartentor
oder ein Fenster auf und zu ist
den macht man auf die einen Seite, das kleine Ding macht man auf die anderen Seite
wenn du Fenster auf und zu machst meldet das
Fenster ist offen, Fenster ist zu
so, dieser Sensor, den gibt es auch in der Variante
dass man noch ein
Temperatursensor anschließen kann
und ich hab mir vor ner Weile die Variante
gekauft, dass man noch nen Temperatursensor
anschließen kann
und
den steck ich jetzt
im Gartenteich
das ist so ein hier, die Dinger sind
von Haus aus wasserdicht
die
so sehen die Dinger aus, Temperatursensoren
der sieht wirklich jetzt ein bisschen aus wie ein Zäppchen
ne, ich hab mir die Simkarten nicht gekauft
Clips 2, ich will mir die aber noch kaufen
10 Euro für 10 Jahre
auch nicht viel Volumen, aber
reicht dafür
und den will ich in den Fischteich hängen
so einen Zentimeter oder so
ein bisschen in den Fischteich unter die Oberfläche
und will ich, dass der mir
alle 6 Stunden nen Report schickt
was die Temperatur im Fischteich ist, denn
damit kann ich mir ableiten
ob ich den Fischteich zudecken muss oder nicht
wenn es nämlich Richtung
Richtung Null geht
von der
Oberflächentemperatur im Fischteich, dann weiß ich
jetzt wirds höchste Zeit
den Fischteich abzudecken, weil
wenn das unter Null geht und anfängt der Fischteich
zu gefrieren, dann platzt
die Wand im schlimmsten Fall
rumherum
und das Ding wird undicht
oder was davor wahrscheinlich passieren wird, dass
die Farbe abplatzt und so was
das zudecken musst du auch noch automatisch
in Auto stellen, ich mir schwierig vor
aber gehen tut alles irgendwie
aber
die Idee
hat was finde ich
wie tief ist der Teich
das ist eine gute Frage
also vorne kann ich noch stehen
hinten kann ich nicht mehr stehen
also ich denke mal
vorne ist der irgendwie was um
1.60
oder so
und hinten dürfte der vielleicht
2.20 oder so was sein
so geraten einfach mal
Sauerstoffsensor habe ich keinen, das ist eine wirklich
sehr gute Idee
ähm, gibt es denn so was?
aha
also
oh das ist
ganz schön teuer
das ist eine gute Idee
weil ich habe da so eine
Pumpe drin, die halt Luft reinpumpt
in den Teich
ist doch wichtig, sonst gibt es so viele
Algen und Gedöns drinne
haha, was GPS
ne wozu
achso ne Moment, was meinst du
was ist denn eine Netzklubkarte
kenne ich nicht
Netzklub klingt nach
irgendeiner Erotik 18 plus Seite
und wo warst du heute
im Netzklub
das sind SIM-Anbieter
ah, von denen habe ich ja nie was gehört
ok, zeig mal
Netzklub
Netzklub IOT SIM
ne
kostenlose SIM-Karte
ja wie verdienen die denn Geld
wenn das kostenlos ist
Sponsor Surf Basic
Moment was soll das sein
SMS Werbung
Moment
mal
Ach nur für 4 Wochen danach kostet das
ist doch bescheuer, das brauche ich das nicht
oder
achso
das ist doch gar nicht kostenlos
was
ohne Grundgebühr
für 4 Wochen
Hi, es ist Yohi
12 Monate, das ist schon Hyper Subscription
zeig mal her
und was haben die mit
ja, aber
was wollen die mir denn sagen
mit ohne Grundgebühr
die gibt es doch auch so
keine Grundgebühr
verstehe ich nicht, also das ist jetzt
wir
ne, warum sollte ich mir
Brave holen
also
so wie ich das sehe
man bekommt
m Daten Volumen
für 0 Euro und man kriegt
irgendwelche SMS Werbung
und jetzt kommt der Trick
ob der geht weiß ich nicht
aber
was ich mit diesen SIM-Karten
ja vorhabe ist
ich möchte die in
den Microcontroller stecken
der dann irgendwo seinen Dienst verrichtet
der kann überhaupt keine SMS
empfangen
was machen die denn
dann
oder meinetwegen
der kann
vielleicht kann der SMS
empfangen aber ich werde sie nie lesen
und E-Mail ist ja auch
kein Ding, ich kann so viele
Web-E-Mail-Adressen machen wie ich lustig bin
das mache ich, das ist
eine echt Big Brain Idee
was muss man da alles angeben wenn man das bestellt
bestellt man, nein nein nein
los gehts, exellent
äh
ach stimmt
man muss ja mittlerweile
muss man ja für Handysachen
sich auch gleich mit Ausweis und Geschiss
registrieren, Alter
wie hieß der andere
wie hieß dieser andere Job
noch ähm andere Anbieter
noch mal die wir letztens hatten für
10 Euro SIM
Lifetime
war das, war das die
One Nice
eh beinahe
macht das jetzt über Amazon
ich habe keinen Bock mich da
mit Ausweis zu registrieren
ich will einfach einen ESP32
gleich mit SIM irgendwo hinstellen
ich will nicht meinen Lebenslauf abgeben
also ich brauche
wirklich nicht viel Übertragungsrate
also für ein bisschen GPS-Daten
übertragen, das sind BITES
das sind BITES, also das ist
nicht viel
ja ich
kann mir gut vorstellen
dass Ausweisregisterung gesetzlich
vorgeschrieben ist, aber ich meine
wenn das ein Anbieter in England ist oder so
ich will einfach meinen Lebenslauf nicht abgeben
ganz ehrlich
und dann klaut mir noch einer den Controller
und macht mit der SIM-Karte irgendeinen Scheiß und
ne
wo konnte man sich den Kram jetzt nochmal kaufen?
hier Shop
du du du du
du
ok die wollen wenigstens keinen Ausweis
die wollen wenigstens schon mal keinen Ausweis hier
IoT-Pilot
auch nicht schlecht
guck ich mal alles nach an
muss ich mir erstmal überlegen
ich brauch es eigentlich gar nicht, ich wollte es nochmal ausprobieren
und ich hab mir überlegt ob ich mein
Laura
Friedhofs
Überwachungsprojekt
nicht doch mit einer SIM-Karte mach
Leute
wisst ihr was
ich weiß wir haben
nicht komplett uns durchgekämpft durch Amazon
aber
ich mir tut
ich hab ganz trockenen Hals, ich muss jetzt was
was trinken gehen
Friedhofsüberwachung, ja
und zwar was ich probiert habe ist
einen Bodenfeuchtigkeitssensor
auf den Friedhof
zu packen
mit ne Microcontroller, sodass ich immer
mitbekomme
wann ich das Grab von Opa und Oma gießen muss
Big Brain
ich bin da auch so öfters mal
aber gerade im Sommer weiß man nie
ob man da jeden zweiten Tag, jeden dritten Tag
hin muss oder ob es mal geregnet hat
und da wollte ich einen Boden
also wirklich einen ganz kleinen Controller
und dann kann man quasi
ich hab es jetzt schon ausprobiert
also das funktioniert prinzipiell
mit Laura schon
1,4 Kilometer
ist das ganze weg, also Übertragung
bei 1,4 Kilometer funktioniert
mit Laura gehts
mit Laura hab ich schon ausprobiert
allerdings
ich stell es mir mit der Simcard
ein bisschen einfacher vor auf Dauer
weil Laura hat ein bisschen rumgespackt
schlechtes Wetter hat nicht richtig funktioniert
und auch so war das nicht so 100% zuverlässig
ich muss halt auch sagen
es sind 1,4 Kilometer
das geht durch Häuser durch
das ist ähm
nicht die besten Voraussetzungen
ähm, deswegen wollte ich es mal probieren
ob es mit der Sim besser funktioniert
zeig mal den besten Deal
lull
hab ich überhaupt einen Deal gefunden
der was getaugt hat
ich bestell mir einen Bosch Professional Knife Set
exellent
das war das einzige, ach ne
ich hab da noch
auf der anderen Seite hab ich noch
äh
irgendwelches Klebeband geordert
total sinnlos
wirklich nix, nix dabei
für mich, was ich brauchen würde
welchen
Spreading Factor hast du genutzt
ich hab das aller langsamste eingestellt
also ich hab
ich hab eingestellt das, ich bin mir nicht mehr ganz sicher
welche Settings da was waren
dass der quasi richtig lang
so nen, so nen, so nen
Indoor macht
und dass der dann auch noch richtig wenig da drin schickt
also
ich hab das langsamste aller Zeiten eingestellt
und das ging, also das
hat schon funktioniert
so Leute, ich muss, ich muss was trinken
und ich muss immer aufs Klo
machts gut, wir sehen uns nächstes mal
tschüss